testing testing one two three does this
work can you hear me
good morning everyone and welcome to the
September 26 2023 meeting of the science
technology and energy Commission
we have a day chock full of interesting
and exciting activity planned for today
we've got a couple of presentations this
morning
which we'll get to in just a minute
and then at one o'clock this afternoon
after a lunch break we will be back for
a full committee work session on the 12
retained bills which we held on to this
past May April and May
and during that work session what we're
going to do is go through the list of
bills and decide
what bills will need a subcommittee then
we will appoint a subcommittee
I will appoint a chair for the
subcommittee and we'll go over the
duties of the subcommittee as well
so that will be our activity for after
the lunch break starting at one o'clock
but to begin our presentations this
morning I would like to call on
representative Tom Corman to introduce
thank you Mr chairman our first speaker
is Professor soroshe vasogi from the
Dartmouth College Department of computer
science and I am pleased to say that he
is a former colleague of mine now that
can be taken in two ways and I mean it
the good way
so um uh sirosh is quite an expert on AI
he's presented in various places and
um
yes you'll you'll need to turn your mic
on Professor thank you
foreign
let's see if this thing shows up
[Music]
great thank you
um
so thank you for having me here and if
you cannot hear me clearly please let me
know and I'll try to speak louder I'll
move the microphone a little closer I
thought I will introduce
uh basically the current advances in AI
today and talk about some of the uh I
guess uh major uh coverage of AI and
talk a little bit about which which of
the coverage is true which is false
which is you know fear-mongering which
is uh actually something to be concerned
about so I titled the talk AI what it is
and what is not
and you know I don't need to motivate
this uh uh for the audience here but uh
basically as you all know AI has been
all over the news recently some of the
coverage positive some of it negative so
thank you
here you can see some example of
coverage of AI that is mainly positive
right so basically
um
the uh how generative AI can lead to a
boom in hiring and so on and so forth
just a couple of examples from just this
summer
but there's actually a lot more negative
coverage of AI and uh you know if you
open up any news Outlet in in in recent
weeks you'll see that there's always
some kind of a doom and gloom coverage
of AI including some as uh you know
I guess sensationalists as this article
like can is AI really the Doom of
humanity so uh
I did a bit of a study where I looked at
the coverage of AI and I found that
there is a two to one basically biased
against AI so twice as many articles are
talking about what AI uh where AI could
go wrong about the third talk about
where AI can actually help you manage so
there's a lot of fear around Ai and so
what I want to discuss today is whether
and you probably uh all notice but there
was a recent meeting at Washington uh
discussing uh regulating AI uh including
a lot of the current tech industry
leaders like the uh CEO of openai Google
and a few other uh big companies so this
is a really current uh topic and
something that uh I think is very
important for legislators to uh be at
least somewhat aware of
so
there's a lot of coverage of AI
most of it uh you know fearful some of
it hopeful but what is AI
most people actually will not be able to
answer that question uh that's because
there's a lot of
basically terminologies and Concepts and
topics that you see being covered in the
news
that are talking about similar things
but uh there's really no uh
understanding of uh you know what is
what so here I have uh shown you some
examples of the topics that you might
have read about in in recent news
coverage of AI
um just uh uh out of curiosity uh
everyone has heard at least half of this
uh uh uh
everyone here I'm assuming has at least
seen half of these topics being
discussed is that correct if if any of
if anyone hasn't seen at least half of
these uh Topics in richer news articles
please raise your hand I want to see uh
right so this is basically something
that is already used right so artificial
intelligence machine learning deep
neural networks deep learning chat GPT
deep fake self-driving cars all related
to AI but actually very different
concepts here I've uh ordered the
concepts into two categories the top
category and the bottom category
um and um you know I I hope you don't
mind me asking some questions while I
you know as I go forward with my talk
but can anyone tell me uh what they
think are is the top category and what
is the bottom category so you have ai
machine learning and deep learning at
the top and at the bottom you have Dolly
chat GPT deep fakes Alexander
self-driving cars any uh
um am I allowed to ask questions or
so what is the uh so there are two
categories the one on the top and the
one at the bottom what do you think uh
these two categories are
you can see them so is AI Concepts the
bottom row is AI implementations so uh
very good yeah so the taboro is
basically Technologies let's put it that
way and the bottom row is the
applications of these Technologies right
so uh AI machine learning and deep
learning into all Technologies chat GPT
Dolly and deep fake Alexa self-driving
cars with all applications the reason
why it's important to separate
technology from applications is because
uh
so um yeah just to uh
show this as uh I just mentioned top Pro
Technologies bottom row applications uh
the reason why it's important to
separate Technologies from applications
is because um
you know Technologies
more or less you can think of them as
being neutral you can use them for good
you can use them for bad uh you know a
car can be uh you know used for good for
transportation you can also use a car to
run people over so Technologies
themselves don't really have uh any kind
of bias towards being you know good or
bad but applications of Technologies do
so uh the um you know examples that I've
given here for instance you can imagine
some of them being a lot more
controversial than others so for
instance Alexa and Siri probably less
controversial deep fakes very
controversial uh uh so this division
between Technologies and applications is
very very important to keep in mind when
discussing AI a good analogy that I use
is
um you know the technology of winged
flight so uh when uh you know the
principal of lift was discovered you
know how you can basically design a wing
so that you get higher pressure at the
bottom of the wing than than top so that
you know you get lift that's the
technology right it's it's wind flight
applications could be you know manifold
could be civilian applications military
applications some for good some for bad
but the technology itself it's it's hard
to say that it's you know good or bad
it's the applications that really need
so I think it's important kind of the
first takeaway should be that when
discussing AI I think it's important to
be discussing applications of AIS AI
more than the technology of AI so uh
even though obviously uh the the
technology is what leads to these
applications is the applications that
could potentially be you know anti or
pro-social depending on how they're used
okay so let's uh
you know dig a little further in and
let's talk about these uh three
Technologies AI machine learning and
deep neural networks or deep learning
um so you have three uh uh circles here
three sets of Technologies uh and there
are different ways they could be related
to each other right so let's uh think
about different Venn diagrams you could
use to uh
um to look at the relationship between
these Technologies
so at the top you have them being
completely you know in the separate
independent Technologies bottom left you
see them overlapping so meaning that
they're the same thing bottom right you
know there's some overlap between them
um I'm curious
um you know the audience uh who thinks
that the top left uh you know diagram is
the correct diagram where these three
things are completely independent
we think the bottom left is correct
where they're all the same thing just
different terminologies and who thinks
the bottom right is correct
okay so it's a trick question none of
these are correct uh but thank you for
participating uh the correct
representation is actually this so AI is
a term that pretty much encompasses all
uh basically machines May begin human
behavior that's General uh definition of
AI machine learning is a subset of AI
where um uh you know the uh the mimika
human behavior is done by exposing the
the system the machine to a lot of data
you can think of it as experience and
the Machine the automatically learns to
mimic human behavior from the data that
it's exposed to
you can imagine there are ways to uh
create a machine that mimics human
behavior that doesn't use data so for
instance if someone hard codes a set of
behaviors or a machine to follow then
that machine it's still called an AI
system but it's not learning from data
right that is the difference we're
talking about a good example of uh that
would be for example the autopilot
system on a plane the autopilot system
on a plane is not it's not a system
that's learned that's learning from data
it's been hard-coded to
fly an airplane basically if he was
learning from data you can imagine that
would be quite problematic as it could
lead to uh you know errors and whatnot
so that's so that's AI as a whole
systems that maybe human behavior
machine learning subset of AI that
learns from data and then deep neural
networks or deep learning
uh if you've heard of it it's just a
subset of machine learning algorithms uh
the uh I guess the defining
characteristics of deep neural networks
is that they rely on massive amount of
data that's one the area is that they
remove humans from the loop so I'll go
into that a little bit but uh you can
imagine
if you're using data to create these AI
systems you could either have humans
provide the data to these systems or you
could have the systems go and find their
own data basically and in some ways
that's what deep neural networks do so
there is a much less Reliance on humans
to provide the data for these models
so why do I have this division because
every
application that I showed you so uh chat
GPT Dolly deep fakes all of those are
actually
fall under the Deep neural networks set
so you know it's AI has been around for
for decades uh it's just the recent
advances in deep neural networks which
is a specific technology uh that will
again that allows AI models to learn
from data for massive amount of data
without much human
um uh uh you know uh oversight these are
the models that have allowed or these
are this is the technology that has
allowed you know these huge advances
that we've seen in recent years like for
before I go further
um like anyone
have a guess why deep neural networks uh
are potentially problematic so you know
we all know that there are potential
there are potential issues with you know
chat GPT deep fakes uh Dolly all of
these systems and as I said they all
fall under the Deep neural network
category any any reason why uh relying
on massive amount of data and removing
humans from the loop could be
problematic yeah yeah go ahead garbage
garbage in garbage out ah there you go
if the bait if the if the data that the
network is using is um flawed or biased
you're going to get bad actions
excellent yes so that's a big one
because if the data is bad then the
output is going to be bad yes
I would just follow with the removing
the humans from the loop uh means that
we could have outcomes that are not
consistent with what we're hoping to
achieve excellent yes anyone else yes
at a practical application I'm seeing uh
one that was not on your original chart
was uh facial recognition and the
mistakes that are often made in that
well
two mistakes is too often when they
convert human life like that
yes uh very good so yes one more
uh I I would say whoever controls the
data has has an awful lot of power
that's also a great Point data being the
beginning of everything so uh if you
think of the pipeline of these models it
all starts from the data so if anyone
someone controls the data then they can
basically control the output of these
models so yes I think uh these are all
great points and they actually get to
exactly uh what I'm going to get into
next uh yeah so this is just saying that
these technologies that we've all seen
in recent years they fall under this
deep neural network category
you know this is just a visualization of
uh you know very simple visualization of
uh kind of the difference between so
again here neural networks are a subset
of machine learning and uh a big
difference between just traditional
machine learning and deep learning is as
you can see the removal of human in the
loop right so uh traditionally this is a
very you know simple example let's say
you have a model that's detecting
whether an image has a tree on it in it
or not so is it a tree or not a tree
very simple model uh traditionally there
were you know there was a lot of input
so these are examples of images of trees
there were people like humans in the
loop labeling these examples and maybe
removing bad examples then you would
train a model and then you get an output
with deep learning that human there's no
longer this human in the loop so this is
a big uh I think uh one of the big
advances which allows for of course
scaling systems up by removing humans in
the loop you can do things much faster
but also so it removes any kind of
oversight that these models usually um
or the machine learning models typically
had in the past
and this is a very very unrealistic
visualization of a neural network but in
case
you know but but it it does uh do a good
uh I guess uh job of uh at least
demonstrating the uh the structure of
neural networks uh it's it's a uh very
uh you know uh again it's a toy example
but uh the general idea is that they're
called neural networks because the basic
uh uh processing units in these networks
are these uh you know nodes we call
neurons that are simple mathematical uh
functions so at the end of the day these
uh uh these models are not magic they
are basically a uh you know Cascade or
collection of mathematical functions
that take data as input they transform
it the data you know through different
layers as you can see here and then they
output some result
at the end of the day it's just math but
what the um
um uh what is kind of unique about
neural networks compared to uh other AI
or machine Learning Systems is that uh
the input that goes into these systems
can just be raw data without any kind of
processing done by uh humans again as as
we saw here we see here so just input
from the raw input from The Real World
goes directly into these models both for
training and uh and and uh you know and
deployment so it removes the human
completely from the loop okay
so
um let's talk about uh one again this is
just a representation of a neural
network uh let's let's focus on one of
the Technologies
um that you know has been making the
news recently which is chat gbt uh it's
a
the technology itself actually is called
uh uh large language models or large
pre-trained language models chat gbt is
an application of such a technology
um so for instance Google and other uh
so chat Tubidy is an open AI tool Google
has its own version Bart and meta is
going to have its own version soon so
these are just different applications of
the same technology large language
models and as you've all if you've
played with child GPT you know that they
can perform many tasks on private humans
and sometimes actually outperforming
humans so it's a great advance in
technology
but um
well and by the way uh I I put this
slide in my talk because even though
it's only recently that people have been
aware of this technology large language
models because of chat GPT it's actually
been out for a couple of years now so uh
gpt3 which is the uh the tech the court
ogpt which is the core Tech behind chat
GPT
has been out for years now so this
article was written in 2020 in the
guardian
it was completely generated by one of
these large language models GPT so again
it's it's uh it's only recently that
because I charge GPD it has uh you know
come to the Public's attention but the
technology itself has been out for for a
couple of years now if you're interested
you can read this article again
completely written by uh uh by gbt3
so it's not it's not new the technology
itself is not new it's a couple of years
old the applications like child GPD
that's new
okay and if you haven't used chat gbt I
really recommend you to play around with
it it's free to use and uh here's an
example of what you can do with child
GPT so uh you know if you just ask it
write an inspiration speech about the
status of chat gbt you can see that you
can generate pretty coherent uh you know
text based on the prompt
in some ways it's uh you know not really
distinguishable from a human writing
okay
so these issues with the large language
models you know are exactly as uh you
know was discussed garbage and garbage
out so very nice uh that was the first
uh comment because they rely on massive
amount of data and there is no uh basic
or very little human oversight if the
data is biased if it's toxic if it's
stereotypical anything is going to be
represented in the output of the model
the model cannot uh uh really separate
good data from Bad data automatically so
that's one of the biggest issues humans
have been taken out of the loop there's
Reliance on massive amount of data and
this data you know I mean there's no
oversight basically it's just the
publicly available data we didn't have
this problem with other AI models in the
past because as uh as I showed here
anything in the green circle that was
not part of machine learning that
doesn't rely on data right so there's no
there's no issue of uh oops garbage in
garbage out
and then even with machine learning
models that do learn from data uh the
the kind of classical machine learning
models have this human in the loop that
allows for
providing oversight to these models it
is deep neural network specifically that
rely on a lot of data without human
oversight that have this issue I just
emphasize that point so garbage and
garbage out a big issue and the uh
obviously if the data that these models
were trained on were good then there
would be no problem but as you may know
the data is actually scraped from the
web so it's a publicly available data on
the internet and you know anyone who's
been on the internet knows that you know
there's some good stuff but there's also
a lot of toxic speech hate speech you
know misinformation there's just all
sorts of things good things and bad
things but again these models are
trained on everything they don't really
uh separate what is good from what is
bad
uh and then the second issue that these
models have is that they're black boxes
so even the people who work on these
models including my lab even though we
understand the the kind of the uh the
math Behind These models we cannot
really explain why these models make the
decisions that they do you know uh
similar to you can think of it as a
human brain I mean a human brain you can
uh or a human with a brain you can ask
it things and you will get responses
back and you might have behavioral
scientists trying to understand how
humans make decisions but it's a it's
it's a big unknown it's really not known
because brands are these huge
complicated systems it's not really
known how exactly the decision-making
process works in the human brain
similarly these neural networks are huge
models that are impossible to really
understand so garbage and garbage out
black box and again it's an issue with
deep neural networks specifically
because of their size so garbage and
garbage out you should be different
networks but because of the Reliance on
data and removal of human oversight
black box issue with deep neural
networks because of their size and
finally
you may have heard this term but they
have a tendency to hallucinate anyone
heard about hallucinations for these
models the
so basically uh because they're so large
sometimes not all the time they can
combine what they've seen
in the data in imaginative ways to
output something that sounds plausible
but it's not
so for instance
you know uh Dolly uh which is if you're
not familiar with Dolly it's an image
creation tool so you're basically write
in a little prompt and it will create
automatically generate an image that
matches the prompt that you've written
so if you ask it to uh create an image
of a cat
sometimes it might and I've seen this
myself it might create an image of a cat
with like three heads right I mean
that's just a very uh clear uh example
of hallucination but uh you know it's
not limited to image only also a text uh
systems like chat GPT uh are prone to
hallucination which means that they make
up information that sounds correct
and the models that's the the uh the
difficult here is that the model itself
thinks the information is correct so the
model is not trying to deceive the user
the model just thinks this is correct
but it's hallucinating so it's not
correct and again this is a problem that
is very specific to this deep normal
networks so I've identified three of
these issues but there were a few others
that were mentioned which are also very
important
um and uh yeah so let's take a little uh
dig a little bit deeper into these three
I'm not sure a little bit of uh math
here I I hope uh that's okay but I just
wanna uh really
um
uh explain when I say these models are
large what I mean by large because it is
the size of these models that make them
black boxes so as I said um you know
machine learning models are not magic
they're basically just mathematical
functions if as you can think of a line
like a simple linear regression line of
best feed as a very simple model it is a
mathematical model that can make
predictions right so you uh have a line
of best you learn a line of best fit now
you have new data coming in new X You
can predict y right that's a very simple
machine learning model it's trained on
data
right that use the data to learn the
line of best speed and you can make
future predictions it's a very simple
model it's a machine learning model
um a simple line like this uh how many
parameters do you think this line has
what is it like an equation for for a
line anyone remember from high school uh
not Tom anyone yes
oh very good yes it does have two
so yeah so it has two parameters The
Intercept exactly the where the line is
intercepting the y-axis and the slope of
the line right if you remember from high
school math y equals MX plus b and being
the slow hope B being The Intercept
doesn't matter the math uh for it but
the idea is that it has two parameters
it's specifying the intercept and the
slope of the line right so this is the
equation for it m and b here are the two
parameters
so these two parameters explain this
model
okay now how many parameters do you
think uh uh these current these deep
neural networks have so if a simple line
has two parameters uh how many
parameters do these deep neural networks
have
Millions
well
I think it goes back to Shannon
basically the number of uh
points that Define a waveform and the
group
you cannot Define a waveform with less
than two points
yeah and it's fuzzy but I think it comes
back to Shannon so for for a line two
points for sure but uh uh uh let's uh
take a step back and like in neurons
excuse me one second I just I couldn't
understand what you said you started
with a line is defined by two points and
then you said how many points is it take
to define something what was the
something oh I'm sorry so um let me
rephrase that so A line is defined by
two parameters the slope and the
intercept
and as I said a simple linear regression
is a machine learning model right it has
two parameters now how many parameters
do you think a deep neural network like
chat GPT has that was the question
and and I think there was a um uh
someone said millions who was that uh so
Millions is a good guess but it's
actually a lower bound so it's actually
hundreds of billions of parameters in
fact the uh the current uh uh GPT model
that's going to be released so in GT5 is
the first trillion parameter models
trillion parameters so that means that
uh you know a line you can understand it
it's it's uh interpretable because you
know it has two parameters you know it's
the slope and The Intercept of the line
you understand it very well now imagine
uh if you had a uh you know model with a
trillion parameters
right it's just there's no way we can
understand how it works so even the
people who uh work on these models have
very little understanding of uh how they
actually work because we cannot imagine
a trillion dimensional space right it's
it's just uh uh outside the scope of our
understanding this is just to make the
point about uh what makes these models
black boxes it's just the fact that they
have so many parameters trillions or
hundreds of billions that is just it's
hard to figure out exactly uh what's
going on inside these models that was
the point I was trying to make yeah I'm
sorry but yes I just like the record to
show that trillions is a bunch of
millions that is true so
hundreds of yes hundreds of or millions
yes so yes current models have hundreds
of billions and again as I said the
newest one is going to have is going to
be the first trillion uh parameter model
and uh you know this came from this from
2022 but Google's uh Palm model this is
two years old already had 550 billion
parameters so now actually if you see
this uh you know what they're talking
about so when they talk about the number
of parameters they mean the number of
mathematical parameters that explain the
model and in this case it's yes go ahead
is a parameter something that's
associated with a sensor that's bringing
could be depending on um you know your
your application if you have sensors
bringing in data yes
what else could it be well it's actually
it's more a function of the uh the model
itself not the data
so uh the same data so let me let me uh
give you a very simple example uh chat
gbt deals with text text is the data the
model itself has billions hundreds of
billions of parameters but I could come
up with a very simple model with a few
parameters that also deals with text but
it's not going to perform well at all
because you know it's uh yeah it's it's
a it's a uh it's a let's let's put it
system specific uh number right so a
chat GPT being a system it has that many
parameters right Dolly has these many
parameters and so on
it makes sense I'm just trying to get a
sense of what limits this is the
parameter that's a really good question
so the limit is how much data you have
to train your model so the more data you
have the more parameters you could have
and also your Computing uh
infrastructure there is a reason why
these models are coming out of kind of
big tech companies and not Academia
because only Google and open Ai and meta
actually have the Computing resources to
learn these things at Dartmouth for
example the best you could do is you
know a few hundred million parameters
like maybe a couple of billion but
nowhere close to what is so I'm going to
move on uh just to uh excuse me just I
just wanted to follow up on this this
thing you had here with the
hallucination now I understand you know
you say you can put something in there
and it'll generate a picture of a cat
with three heads that becomes obvious
well that's not a real cat everybody
knows that but what if it generates some
something much more complicated than
that and data then how does one
determine women if that's hallucination
or not because people are going to look
at the outputs of these things people
say oh I read it on the internet it was
under this and so it's real but it's
actually artificial so is there any way
of running it through a second uh uh
scenario or some way of checking that to
determine what's real and what isn't
that's a really good question and
something that my lab and others are
working on right now the answer is
currently no and that's why it's a big
issue um the uh unless it's obvious like
you said like a cat CAD with three heads
uh there's no because the model itself
thinks that it's true that's the problem
right and so it's actually there's no
way uh to automatically
figure out whether something is a
hallucination or not and that is a huge
issue I'll actually get to that in a
second but I just I just want to follow
a question so would it be possible to
run it through Model A and it comes out
with some set of data and says this is
this is all facts and we think this the
model thinks this is all correct if you
ran it through a separate model that was
different and they didn't come out the
same would that be kind of a key
indication that one of them was wrong
yes uh so that's a a really good
suggestion it would at least tell you
that there's inconsistency right but it
won't tell you which one is right right
yeah I understand that but another
problem but that would be one way to do
it uh there are a couple of uh issues
with that one is that there are only a
few of these models out there because as
I said just because of the size you know
there are only a few companies that
actually make can make models like that
and secondly they're all trained on
publicly available data from the web and
so the the kind of this garbage in
garbage out principle that they're
getting the same garbage in and so you
know they don't have independent data
sets that trained on and that is a big
issue and in fact it could be creative I
could just interrupt for a second please
uh representative Harrington let's save
the questions for right after he
finishes his presentation which is going
to be real soon now right yes yes okay
thank you thank you all right so um
I'm just gonna uh talk a little bit
about the garbage in garbage on and the
hallucination
um you know I I can't skip this uh for
the interest of time but I just wanted
to uh
at least provide some uh you know uh
understanding of how these large
language models work it's not as I said
magic it's it's all it is it's what the
model has seen in the past so let's take
an example of uh at the very bottom
right so like as I said large language
model is a technology that chat GPT and
other tools use so you can for the red
box you can just think it says chat GPT
now if you pass as a user if you write I
was walking down the street and pass it
to rgbt to complete you know it could
finish your sentence to make it some
coherent things I was walking down the
street and then it would generate when I
saw my friend for example it's just a
very simple example that's how these
things usually work they take a prompt
and then they generate text based on the
prompt that you've given at the uh
um the way it is work is that uh based
on the data that they have seen so this
is the data from the web uh they uh
have a probability distribution of which
word should come next based on what is
already being said so you're talking
about I was walking down the street so
this is what already being said and now
the model uh has a distribution of what
is the most likely word that comes after
this uh these series of words and here
I'm showing you this is a toy example
but you can imagine the model so the bar
being the probability the model uh
thinks that okay when is pretty common
and is less common at you know is even
less common and so on and it randomly
picks one of these choices uh based on
this probability distribution so it's
not it's not that each word has a uh has
the same
likelihood of being chosen when is more
likely to be chosen than and because it
has a higher probability right but it is
at the end of the the uh randomly chosen
this is important that's why if you pass
the same prompt to uh chat gbt you can
get a different generation every time
because you know you could be picking a
different word every time and then once
it has it when it once it picks the
first word now the prompt becomes I was
walking down the street when and then
again it looks for the next word uh that
is the most probable work so when I and
then so on and so forth so this is a
gross over simplification but it's it's
a good uh you know intuition uh to have
around how these large language models
work work they are at their core next
word prediction models they predict what
word should come next given what's
already being said and that prediction
is based on what they've seen underwear
right so what am I telling you this is
because well if what they've seen on the
web is garbage then and their
predictions are going to be garbage too
so garbage and garbage out and then
finally
um hallucination uh we already had a
discussion around this but uh a really
good example of this is this uh a case
that I don't know if you've heard of
this but in in the summer there was this
case where a lawyer in New York uh
basically wrote his whole uh legal brief
using chat GPT but it ended up uh GPD
ended up hallucinating a lot of legal
cases that didn't exist so it basically
uh you know cited a lot of it it cited
legal cases that Enix exists including
proper citations and everything and the
judge was looking for these and they
couldn't find it and anyways the lawyer
got into a lot of trouble but um that's
an example of a non you know obvious
hallucination right it looks legit
citations like the citations even
included you know years and authors or
everything and every and they made sense
for someone who actually hadn't seen the
uh you know citations that made sense
and as a really good example of
hallucination I think for the interest
of time I can stop here and then take
more questions well I want to thank you
I know this is an incredibly complex
topic and you did a great job of
condensing it into something that we
could understand and absorb and I know
the committee has lots of questions for
you unfortunately we only have 20
minutes of questions before we have to
call it off but I will ask everybody to
raise your hand before uh speaking and
I'll call on you to to ask a question of
the professor so we'll go with Lucius
we have another presentation at 11.
okay
representative Wendy Thomas
thank you
um what kinds of laws are you seeing
that are specific for AI and and in
particular in the political world with
propaganda
about the use of AI for propaganda
um just the the use of AI in general are
you seeing any specific laws being
generated
yes so uh you may know that EU is
actually like Germany was one of the
first countries to uh uh
specifically uh regulate the use of
charge gbt for public employees and if
I'm not mistaken I think even the state
of Maine had a uh you know uh hold on
the use of and others can check this for
me but basically public employees uh are
not allowed to use chat gbd for the next
couple of months as they figure out
basically what's uh what's going on I
believe that's correct a state of Mass
or neighboring state
um and in terms of uh other laws well
there's a lot of discussion uh in uh EU
I think EU is definitely leading uh the
way for laws and regulations uh I do
want to
make a point here this is my own
personal opinion which is if you're
thinking about laws and regulations it's
important to have this distinction
between application and Technology right
I don't think regulating the technology
makes sense maybe regulating the
application of it makes sense right so
you don't want to uh you know stop
innovation in AI That's the technology
but yes applications of it I can imagine
uh you know potentially be something
that could be regulated representative
Summers
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh being a network
engineer myself I'll be the first to
admit I use chat BG gbt and I and I've
even cheated and downloaded python code
to create an API so it does work but the
question I had was is that uh I have
noticed also on searches you can get a
uh you know as of 2021 this is not known
to happen as is there a oh I can I can
guess there's never going to be
absolutely current is there like a set
timeline of how out of date the data
would be an API
yeah that's a great question because
these uh models are so large and so
expensive to train you cannot uh retrain
them often and uh the uh I believe chat
gbt actually if you look at at the very
bottom it says like when was the last
time it was like where was the time
frame that it was trained on I believe
the most recent one is uh 2022 uh like
that's like yeah but that's a really
good point which is uh because these are
trained on large data sets and let's say
they're retrained every year that means
that they're actually behind in terms of
what is common knowledge and common uh
understanding yeah
representative William McWilliams
thank you chair Rose thank you very much
Professor for the presentation
um I have a question about blockchain in
terms of using blockchain as part of um
proving where data comes from and
by extension
if there is anything we can do to set
rules for blockchain to prove data for
just as an example deep fakes right
blockchain would dissolve the underlying
supports of a deep fake because it
proves that it's not actually based on
the truth is there a way as
for us as legislators
to implement blockchain
checkpoints to make sure that moving
forward what we're seeing is the truth
so
um yeah thank you for the question uh I
have to say blockchains are definitely
outside my office expertise but I can uh
comment a little bit on it but I can't
comment down to technology much um what
is uh true is that blockchain can be
used to in some ways a watermark you
know uh data uh and so and I know people
have been talking about it with respect
to uh uh deep fakes so in some ways you
can imagine you know having a built-in
uh verification of all right is this is
this a real image or is it a generated
image right
um and I know there are uh you know
people who are working on this again
outside my area of expertise I do know
that this is much harder for text so for
image it's much easier than uh than for
text because you can imagine it's hard
to Watermark a piece of text and there
are again
um discussions around this uh you know
so maybe
you know you have some kind of a um
I don't know like mathematical function
encoded into the text that to the uh to
the you know naked eye it just looks
like a act like a normal piece of text
but if you run it through this you know
analysis tool it'll tell you whether it
was generated by an AI or by human there
are discussions around this um but I
don't know of anything that's really
taken off and again I not being an
expert on blockchains I can't really
comment more than that yeah mm-hmm
representative muttons has a question
thank you maybe as a follow-up to that
and what you had said earlier
um
if if if
we were to do or any legislature were to
do any type of Regulation where where
should the regulation focus should it be
on
the data that's going into the black box
the Black Box itself or requiring that
there be some kind of human
check on the output to control against
hallucinations or is it all of the above
yeah that's a great question
um one uh kind of idea that's been uh
that we've been talking about in
academic circles is uh creating what we
call a model nutrition labels you know
how food have uh nutritional labels of
you know what goes in them so at the
very least
requiring uh some kind of a uh like a
like a label that explains uh exactly
where the data for this model came from
you know what are the potential issues
with the data all of those things I
think that would be the very least that
can be done so it won't stop uh the uh
the development of these applications
but at least consumers they know what
they're getting right right now you know
chat GPD they don't know exactly so
having what we call like a model
nutrition label I mean it's a bad term
but uh that that I think would be
um would be very useful and then the
other um
uh and by the way these nutrition labels
could be then uh part of it could be
having uh human oversight so in order to
actually get the label maybe you need to
have uh you know some human oversight uh
over the generation or uh or over the uh
you know data that's actually used to
train these models uh and um the other
area which I think uh would be you know
useful to look at and this is a little
bit for selfish reasons because I do
work in Academia but uh I think a big
issue with current uh uh advances in AI
is that a lot of is driven by industry
because of the uh again the resources
required to create such models and we
try to play catch-up and we try to
actually you know take a step back and
analyze these models and figure out
exactly what's wrong with them but I
think uh you know uh having uh I'm not
sure you can force corporations to to uh
you know uh partner with academics but
having some uh venue uh some some uh you
know uh I guess uh way for academics to
get access to some of these models would
be very useful so we can use these
models like everyone else can but we're
not actually given access to the uh
training data to the model architecture
or anything like that so you know if you
had access to these we could definitely
uh uh you know look at some of these
issues and come up with methods to
mitigate them but we don't have access
to them so access to academics I think
would be another possible event you know
way to do this representative Harrington
thank you Mr chairman let me take my
question just a follow-up to what we
were talking about with the
hallucination stuff I'm just trying to
figure it so it generates a product that
comes out that may be inaccurate but the
model believes it is accurate now so
that presents
presents some more results does that
results then go back into the data
package so that if a similar question or
a follow-up question is answered now
it's being based on what we what is
possibly false consumptions from the
first hallucination which only
perpetuates itself for making the second
one worse does it yeah that way uh
that's a great question uh it doesn't
work immediately like that but a big
concern is exactly what you said which
is uh people are going to be using these
tools a lot like and they're going to
produce new data and that data is going
to be a you know posted on the web and
the next version of chat gbt is going to
be using that data and so it's going to
basically have this feedback loop where
absolutely if they're like you know
hallucinations in the data you could
just kept get getting fed back into the
models and that is a huge issue
absolutely
representative Gorman has a question
thank you Mr chairman
given that the Deep neural Nets are
currently incapable of producing an
explanation for their output has there
been research to modify them so that
they can produce an explanation
yeah that's a great question as well um
yes including some from my own lab so uh
we there's been kind of two uh
directions taken one is uh what we call
kind of post-talk interpretability
method so you're given a model let's say
chat gbd and then our tools try to
interpret how these models work you can
think of it as kind of a uh you know a
behavioral scientist trying to
understand how you know dogs you know
make decisions or something like that
that's one way the other is to actually
change the models uh
from the beginning so that they are
inherently interpretable so instead of
you know kind of doing this post hoc all
right we have a model now let's try to
interpret it what if you actually had
models ever you know inherently uh
interpretable so we are working on that
uh it is it is uh you know the first
area has you know Advanced quite a bit
so these post hoc methods the second
area is a very new area of research
which is uh making uh neural networks
internally interpretable one of the
issues uh as I said earlier is the fact
that um it's it's uh it's hard for
academics to work with such large models
just within the resources we have in
Academia and so as I said like if if
there was some kind of
way to partner with corporations uh uh
to give us access to these models I
think it would really speed up the
development of such uh such Solutions
yeah
representative McGee did you have a
question I do thank you yes
um this conversation is just getting
interesting
um I was just going to say to follow on
what you're talking about now
uh going back to garbage in garbage out
if the systems have this incredible
exponential capability to be able to
review the data then it kind of comes
down to the sort of the Prime directives
that are being given to it by who
whoever is creating these applications
to
put some
or maybe government really needs to play
that role of trying to put in uh
quality in terms of output right because
it it won't do it on its own so it has
to be like a prime directive like an
iRobot that you can't hurt humans or
whatever right you have to
maybe have government be responsible for
making sure that the folks who control
the data
uh don't have so much power over that
data that it then harms the citizens so
I you know I think from the conversation
that we've had so far I I come from a
systems background I was a program
manager in software engineering and I
know that unless you define the things
up front that are your objectives for
those applications and unless people in
government understand the objectives of
each then we may not be giving the
correct
inputs uh up front for having the
applications provide what they could
provide right we can keep them on the
good path
at least it seems like that's where
we're at right now is trying to figure
out how do we keep them on the good pass
and I think government can interject
that universities
um be part of the process rather than
having it all be in private Industries
hands because I think you get different
outcomes
yes I agree with that and you know uh
the other than obviously academics
having different goals than people
working in the corporate world we're
more interested in you know kind of
scientific understanding of what's going
on we're also um you know there's a lot
of us we had a lot of graduate students
so we can really study these systems at
scale so I agree with you 100 and in
terms of um uh what you were saying
earlier I think an analogy I sometimes
use is you know um you have research
let's say you're looking at uh for uh
you know uh pharmaceutical research
right so the research being done on
drugs the actual technology right it's
done in labs and uh you know there's
very little usually for the research
itself there's little government
oversight but then once you want to move
that technology to a real world
application like a drug then you have
the FDA basically uh making sure that it
passes certain muster before it can be
deployed in the real world right I think
we can make it same analogy here where
we can you know leave the technology
alone more or less or let it develop in
Labs but then once they're being moved
to real world applications like chat
chipity and address then some Department
like the FDA but for AI you know where
they can just take these models and then
they can verify the same way FDA you
know verifies drugs to make sure that
they're safe for public consumption I
think that would be a good compromise it
it removes any kind of hurdle for taking
a lot technological development but it
also protects the public
I'm going to ask the final question and
follow-up representative McGee's
question by saying or by asking if
these applications are scraping the web
for data and we know how huge
the amount of data is
is it even possible to control
um
the short answer is no
so we can't control it but you know we
can try to at least understand it and
provide some insight but yes it's uh if
if we are going to continue relying on
the web as a source of data it's uh
almost impossible to completely control
this output
well I want to thank you very much for a
very stimulating and exciting
presentation and discussion and I
commend you for
condensing it down to a a one-hour
period that we could actually
get something out of we really
appreciate it you did an excellent job
thank you for having me thank you
Mr chairman will the slides be available
say again the slides that he used but
he'd be available can you make your
slides available sure uh who do I need
to send it to send them to okay yes okay
all right
all right uh we're gonna start our next
presentation in two minutes if you need
to go to the bathroom uh while our next
presenter gets set up we'll wait until
uh just about 11 o'clock and then we'll
okay let's resume our activity for this
morning before we get to our next
presenter I just want to provide one
piece of information for members of the
committee
you may have noticed that one of our
members Troy murner is not here this
morning and that's because
representative merner resigned his seat
in the house
uh last week so he's no longer a member
of the house or obviously a member of
this committee
I'm currently working with speaker
Sharon Packard to find a new member for
our committee and that person hopefully
will be in attendance uh with the rest
of us early next month
so with that I'm going to ask
representative Corbin to introduce our
next speaker
thank you Mr chairman my pleasure to
introduce Meredith anguin as a working
chemist Meredith anguin headed projects
that lowered pollution and increased
reliability on the electric grid her
work included pollution control for
nitrogen oxides and gas-fired combustion
turbines and corrosion control and
geothermal and nuclear systems she was
one of the first women to be a project
manager at the Electric Power Research
Institute where she led projects in
renewable and nuclear energy
in the past 10 years she began to study
and take part in Grid oversight and
governance for four years she served on
the Coordinating Committee for the
consumer liaison group associated with
ISO New England her our local grid
operator and Ms anguin teaches courses
and presents workshops on the electric
grid she is also an advocate for nuclear
energy her previous major book was
campaigning for clean air strategies for
pro-nuclear advocacy she's been a
featured speaker at several nuclear
events including being a keynote for the
worldwide nuclear science week in 2018
on a personal note I started noticing
Meredith popping up on my own Twitter
feed now known as X feed and I
ultimately realized that she lives in
Wild River romant which is you know I
can almost throw a stone there so I had
lunch with her a few months ago and
asked if she'd be willing to give us a
presentation and here she is so thank
thank you very much for asking me I'm
very happy to be here
and
uh
so this is just the beginning slide as
you can see it says who I am and where
we are and luckily for me uh uh
representative Corman did a lovely
introduction so I don't have to uh write
a lot about it uh right to talk about
all this I just want to say that I was
active in the consumer and liaison group
of iso New England and I also have this
book shorting the grid the hidden
fragility of our electric grid which has
gotten quite a lot of
circulation
I want to start by saying that uh
my pilot My Philosophy is very much that
this a strong grid is a reliable grid a
reliable grid is extremely important and
if you go to anywhere where they don't
have a reliable grid they'll tell you
that and the next thing is relatively
inexpensive electricity so electricity
can be used for health and happiness and
electricity made with low levels of
pollution and ecosystem disruption
so here's the that's I just wanted to
say that first because sometimes you
hear a presentation on the grid and it
sounds like the purpose of the grid is
to be Net Zero that is something that a
grid can be May should be but it isn't
the purpose of the grid the purpose of
the grid is to make reliable electricity
so here's my presentation outline
and uh the I'm going to talk first about
the physical grid and the policy grid
there are really two grids that people
talk about and they get them confused a
little or maybe they mean to get them
confused the physical grid you can see
it out your window okay there's
transmission there's distribution
there's substations there's Dispatchers
in the uh in the balancing Authority
operators room there's linemen there's
generators there's end users and it's
mostly limited by physics not by
regulations what happens on that grid
policy grid includes things like Net
Zero net metering renewable portfolio
standards and so forth and to be honest
the policy grid is mostly about how the
physical grid is paid
paid and policy is kind of the same word
so here's a situation where the two
grids were confused uh Vermont Yankee
was a nuclear plant and it had contracts
with Vermont utilities that ended in
2012. and it continued operations
selling into the grid operator auctions
until 2014.
in 2013 anti-nuclear people said you can
shut it down we don't need it we're not
even using it now but we were using it
because Vermont Yankee was putting power
on the grid and people were using it
changing a contract does not change the
wires and it's very important to keep
that in mind or you can get really
misled by people who have some advocacy
position or not or people who are just
confused
and there's as I've been working on this
I realized there's actually a third grid
and they're multiplying uh it's the
could Grid it's the grid you usually
hear about uh it's so good that's in the
Sunday Sunday paper
for example with battery breakthroughs
we could use just wind and solar
forget those Legacy plans because
something is just around the corner now
I want to tell you that I worked at the
Electric Power Research institution we
did research and research does not turn
into deployment very quickly so I have
concentrated on the grid we have and I
find that people know comparatively
little about it compared to the could
grid
so let's start with the grid we have
and I want to talk about Regional
transmission organizations first
I have a friend in Chicago who's very
knowledgeable very I went to University
of Chicago with me and she had no idea I
said to her how is it being in pjm in
the middle of myso she didn't know what
I was talking about
but here's what I was talking about
these are the regional transmission
organizations and you can see that the
pjm area uh was
um was meant to be it started out as
Pennsylvania Jersey Maryland that's why
it's pjm and you notice that it's
Chicago too meanwhile most of the middle
west is on uh is miso uh Mid-Continent
in uh ISO then there's a Southwest power
pool and the one we've all heard of this
is the one everybody sort of ercot
anybody ever heard that is the grid of
of most well-known Creed in the country
so you say okay those are the regional
transmission organizations that operate
in a certain way what's all the white
space the white spaces areas that have
the traditional vertically integrated
utilities that are mostly controlled by
a combination of their Public Utilities
commissions and the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission the RTO areas have
a layer of of control that is uh the the
well the
um
Regional transmission organization and
and and sometimes they're called isos
and there's there's a little bit of
difference between the two but don't
worry about it if it's an ISO or an RTO
it acts a certain way
so here's the two major tribes of of
grid governance there are traditional
vertically integrated utilities where
the utility is responsible for
reliability it owns power plants and
Distribution Systems transmission is a
little more complicated because ferc is
a very
um
has a lot of control uh feds have a lot
of control on transmission it receives a
rate of returns set by regulations that
is if it invests a million dollars in a
new power plant it's Public Utilities
Commission will say you can regain that
million dollars from the rate payers and
you can um
you can get an eight percent rate of
return on that million dollars as your
profit the Public Utility Commission has
to say that or it can't get any of the
that the puc has that control and
um in an RTO area which is sometimes
called deregulated but please
nobody is ultimately responsible uh for
the reliability I'm sorry to say that
but it is true the merchant generators
Supply Power they are not owned by your
a local utility they do not have a
strong obligation to be on all the time
as a matter of fact they aren't
uh distribution utilities by that power
and auctions run by the rtos so for
example if you
um I don't know if you
if you're a a rural Cooperative say and
you don't have your own power plant but
uh you can get power two ways you can
make a power purchase agreement with a
power plant or uh you can get your power
at an auction run by the uh rtos and the
the rules for these auctions and the
rules for uh what the puc is allowed to
do and what the RTO is allowed to do
they are very complex and in my opinion
quite easily games now a lot of people
would be mad at me for saying that but
what do I mean by easily gamed
well first of all I want to show you
what we we owe so much to these people
this is the control room at ISO New
England and it is a control room
everywhere the the the name for a
control room is the balancing Authority
well it's also called the control room
but various things with the grid
operator does includes paying the plants
and so forth and so on but the balancing
Authority is the ultimate
responsibility Place uh they they keep
the demand the amount of electricity
used and the supply the amount produced
in Balance all the time so they're the
ones who would say this power plant has
to go on now we're getting we're getting
a spike in demand or they would say
we're going to start rolling blackouts
or they would say we've got three
companies that are the demands going up
and up and we don't have more to meet it
we have three companies that have told
us they're in for demand resource we can
tell them to shut down and they will
they were telling them to shut down so
these are the people who do it and
there's several different desks uh it's
not just one person doing it there's
several different desks looking at
things like how the pipe gas pipelines
are going LNG tanker tracking and the
first time I was there I was like what's
with the big TV screens well the thing
is the big TV screens are about uh
activities in the area that might affect
demand I think instead of talking about
that I'll I'll mention uh the uh the the
big example is is is Britain okay uh in
Britain lots of people watch the soccer
games and there are breaks in the soccer
games and at that point everybody uh
plugs in their electric kettle so uh
what happens is that the the grid
operators are watching the soccer games
so they know to order plants online when
the electric kettles come on so anyway
this is the kind of thing it's
complicated to do
and this is uh this is a slide that Phil
hands are used I turned out I was giving
a talk and Phil Hansel was giving a talk
and I said Phil I haven't seen you for
decades we were both at every together
so at any rate let me just say this is
his slide and uh it shows the different
um the different usage okay so you have
a base load which is nuclear coal uh
combined heat and power uh minimum
operating letters for gas and oil
thermal there's this whole thing about
minimum dispatch you can't tell a plant
to put out less than it would be stable
at putting out and some Hydro then
intermediate rolled gas oil thermal
hydro and then Peak load which would be
gas peaking turbine hydro and pumped
hydro and demand response so those are
the different uh different uh levels of
uh okay this um
this is a picture of the problem that
all grids have which is varying demand
this is a pretty old picture but it
doesn't change that much so you see the
the uh the forecast to demand I took
this picture or two in the afternoon 2
45 uh screenshot the forecasted Demand
on the iso New England system is the
blue line and the actual demand is the
orange line and they're tracking each
other pretty well and and the grid
operator is is using the blue line as
his base and then trying to figure out
what's really going on uh with the uh
Orange Line okay now um
I also wanted to say something which is
like where is this picture misleading
you
that line isn't zero it's the bottom
that line is ten thousand megawatts in
other words the amount of power needed
on the grid it doesn't fall below ten
thousand megawatts in this picture
and I think that's important to remember
because people uh don't don't they say
there is no such thing as base load I
said well what is that 10 000 megawatts
so let's look for a moment at how the
rtos work the energy auctions uh the
energy auctions run every five minutes
it's economic dispatch which means the
highest price plant sets the clearing
price for all plants so let's say that
we have a plant that bids in a twenty
dollars per megawatt hour another 30 and
plan C at 40 and the grid operator needs
all of them all the plants a b and c
will get the Forty dollar per megawatt
clearing price now if the grid operator
doesn't need some of them it says okay I
need a and I need B but sorry I see
you're out of it this time we just don't
have that much demand then all the
plants will get the uh thirty dollar
clearing price
it's uh it's pretty straightforward
except that
sometimes it isn't
so I want to show you a little bit about
base load remember I told you that that
10K is 10 000 megawatts that's on the
grid all the time that's needed on the
grid all the time okay so these uh our
size of courtesy of Israel
Senator veranche who's the founder of a
group called radiant value management
and it's about New York it's about base
load in New York
so here's New York City
uh from January to December in uh 19 uh
and the jaggedy thing is the amount of
Demand on the grid which as you can see
gets really big in July and August right
that's uh that's the big time that's the
uh uh uh
air conditioning time now
I don't like to get into what's going to
happen but if you think about we're
going to Electrify heating also what do
you think is going to happen to this
diagram
it's going to go way up in the winter in
the winter also and you notice that he
has um
uh the highest that it gets is uh eight
thousand eight hundred and thirty seven
megawatts and if you remember our entire
grid was getting up to 14 000 megawatts
and this is a New York City alone going
up to 8 000. and the lowest is three
thousand so really
somewhere between the intraday low and
the minimum average somewhere around
4000 megawatts is needed all the time
and at Peak it goes to eight thousand
now somebody's going to say to me yeah
Meredith that's the city that never
so here is the uh another slide that he
did where he went around to the
different areas in New York City and he
put
um again for 2020 but this is for the a
whole year okay this isn't by month this
is by area
and uh so um for example capital is the
Albany area Genesee is up up by
Rochester Long Island is Long Island New
York City is New York City I think it's
pretty straightforward and and you can
look up these areas uh uh anyway that's
not the point is that the the Orange is
what's there all the time on the grid
what's needed all the time on the grid
and the yellow is what is the jaggedy
part above that lower line
okay
so
then he did an analysis of it and it
turns out New York City is not an
outlier New York City is 65 percent
um uh 24 7 demand okay but everything
else is is 66 68 61 62 there's one
that's a 54. but what I'm trying to say
is if somebody says there ain't no such
thing as Grace base load
um well you can say there ain't no such
thing as a free lunch either so you do
need that base load you need the
okay now I'm going to go on to talking
about the Grid in Winter because around
here that is the tense time on the grid
and I do want to be sure that I don't go
over so I'm keep looking over there okay
that clock is just a few minutes fast
just FYI thank goodness thank you
so I wanted to show you the Texas energy
crisis because it's sort of like our
energy crisis but it was much more
spectacular and got a lot of of coverage
so
this is in 2021
and this is from the eai Energy
Information Administration and this is
urcot the one RTO you've all heard of so
it turned out
that at the beginning on Sunday February
7th we urquhot was doing great with uh
20 gigawatts of wind now you understand
that our our little grid only goes up to
20 gigahertz of wind okay
and that's big for us
but then the wind died down and the
weather got colder and so as is expected
natural gas was on the job that's what
is the grid backup when the wind dies
down the natural gas is the backup and
just to some extent every every time you
put until something changes I'm not
looking forward to uh how it's all going
to be different but until something
changes every time you put on a wind
turbine you better have natural gas
around or you or or maybe something else
so fuel is key for winter reliability oh
I have to go back to this for a minute
this drop here
was when they couldn't get natural gas
the drop around Sunday night I was
actually up watching it I was so I I
knew they were going to have to shed
load it was just they did
and uh they they led to blackouts one of
the problems with blackouts is they
planted a blackout would last for an
hour and then the power would go back on
and then they'd black out a different
area that's called a rolling blackout
because the area that is blacked out
goes from one place to another
but actually what happened is they
couldn't roll them and so places were
blacked out for 48 hours
which led to what 200 deaths something
like that I don't know
so fuel is key for rental reliability
what what was the problem with the
natural gas there were a lot of problems
with it but one of them is that natural
gas is delivered as needed and something
tend to interfere with that delivery a
pipe can be turned off there can be too
much requirement for how Heating and
natural gas and that that that is fuel
stored on site is key for winter
reliability
so uh
oil coal and nuclear reactor fuel are
there they're just there okay uh and
other types of fuel can be replenished
by delivery Water behind the dam is
okay so our grid operator in 2018
had a very successful program
and there's a ISO New England cold
weather reports you can find it on the
web and I say New England and anyway
um this is a report that was done on
this and this show what what I saw New
England did was it said okay the um the
power plants won't be able to get
natural gas we can see this coming
because it's going to be very cold and
uh there's going to be demand for
um Home Heating and it's just not going
to be a good scene so they said okay we
are going to underwrite
generators keeping oil on site there are
many what's called dual fire generators
that can burn either oil or natural gas
and we're going to keep
underwrite them keeping oil on site it
wasn't a hundred percent but it was like
we know that you don't want to do this
because you can't promise to get
reimbursed for it but we're going to
help you do it
so here's exactly what happened uh that
month I I have a book but I didn't put
this in the book because everybody told
me that it's invisible
the green is the oil that was purchased
through the iso New England reliability
program
the little
blue at the top is generators that
didn't have the iso reliability program
and also purchase some oil
so that that program kind of worked you
know
okay
it was near failure though because this
the same report for myself New England
oil uh depleted on site
it started out they could get nine days
worth of oil and then as the uh but they
only on the first of on December had
like eight days work of oil then things
began getting really cold and and and
they weren't able to get gas and by the
9th of January they had one day's worth
of oil
well it worked it warmed up
also oil can be delivered uh more easily
than natural gas if it's being used by
homes for heating
so here's my okay so far
I have been very much just the facts
ma'am I tried to give you just facts I'm
now going to be opinionated
my feeling is there's a fatal Trifecta
for a grid there's over-reliance on
Renewables that start and stop at their
own schedule like when all that wind
died out in in in in Texas
or and backing up the Renewables with
natural gas delivered just in time
through Pipelines
and things can interfere with that
delivery it can be rooted to homes there
can be freezings freezing wet valves all
kinds of stuff and the third part of the
trifecta
is well we'll get some from The
Neighbors
let me tell you the neighbors are having
the same weather you're having and I
first noticed this years ago before when
I was just writing a Blog I wasn't
writing my book I hadn't joined the
consumer liaison group we had a real
cold spell and all of a sudden we were
getting about half the energy from Hydro
Quebec that we usually get hey wait a
minute guys you're supposed to help us
no they had their own problems and they
could not send us more than than they
usually sent as a matter of fact they
sent less and uh in the winter
um they are the report that I mentioned
if you look at the footnotes
the winter operations report that I've
quoted before you look at the footnotes
it turns out that a hydro Quebec makes a
um
a capacity Supply application that's
about half of what they usually send us
so when they stop sending us in much and
they sent us half they were not
so natural gas is a just in time
delivery and in an ordinary day our God
our grid runs around 50 percent natural
gas fired in Winter power plants compete
with homes for natural gas and people
run space heaters which increases the uh
neutral electricity and that's how oil
I mean I I have two of those sorry about
that
when I'd put two of them on therefore
okay New England
uh after that you would say this is a
really good story and it ended happily
but first said no no
you're into reliability program is not
fuel neutral it's not Market based and
so you have got to think of something
else
so it there came uh two more programs
which are both in place now paper
there are different bases for these two
new programs there's the legal trans it
isn't a matter of like oil on this on
site okay they're they're more
complicated but you know I think that
some of these places are
are really good at providing complex
situations for lawyers to argue about so
I don't mind I mean I'm not a lawyer and
my my beloved Aunt may she rest in peace
was a lawyer so I'm not anti-lawyers but
every now and again I think is all this
necessary
anyhow there's a the new programs the
capacity markets is
um
uh a pay for performance and that is
that um if you uh are called on in when
the grid is stressed to put your plant
online and you don't do it then you have
to pay some of your capacity payment to
a plant that did it
the plant who came online gets extra
money and you get fined and so that's
how uh and I did not get into the
capacity auctions okay this is supposed
to be half an hour and I don't want you
to go home saying well that was
something okay I want you to understand
what I'm saying mostly at least
so anyway the the um then so that's the
legal construct of if you don't come
online you have to pay money to a plant
that did come online
and then there's some inventory and
energy program which is sort of The
Rebirth of the um
uh
The Rebirth of the rental reliability
program
and it is pays per day
for fuel on site and of course there are
rules about oh how much it pays and what
fuel on site means and stuff but it it
it it is basically it isn't just a legal
construct it's it's about actual fuel
that you can use oddly only certain
types of fuel are eligible uh not
nuclear not coal and as a matter of fact
I've been I've been reading a bunch of
stuff recently about
um
uh
uh ferc is is an ISO New England are are
fighting about a little bit about
whether Water behind the dam qualifies
or not apparently it doesn't and but
water in a pump storage facility
qualifies this is the kind of thing I
mean by uh you know there's a lot of fun
for people in these projects also I
would like to say that uh the program is
is not really about results in my
opinion and LNG seems pretty key in this
program but I I invite you to to look
into the uh inventoried energy program
yourself
um I also want to say that it's very
important a fast response is important
the fastest are hydro plants and
batteries and the next fast is a simple
uh gas turbines however uh keeping them
ready for Fast Response takes fuel
simple gas turbines we used to call it
hot standby but that's not that's not
considered a a modern term anymore I
don't know what they call it but
basically you can't start even a gas
turbine from Total scratch and to keep
it going to the point you can start it
takes fuel steam plants and combine
cyclical gas plants are are slower
so I'm going to look forward a little
here
and I want to well I'm going to look
forward a little and I'm going to uh
talk a little bit about the could grid
though I don't like to because I it's
just hard enough to keep track of what
ferc is doing about water behind what
kind of dam without getting involved in
assessing different technologies that
might happen
but here we go
um the local code grid is very heavily
dependent on wind we are hoping for
offshore wind and and and that's what's
happening however in recent months
offshore wind developers have been
either pulling out or calling for very
high price increases for uh this is from
utility dive you can you can look it up
yourself
um
and uh it it is 48 uh
for contract prices uh and and uh solar
prices to go up 63 percent and these are
mostly from New York information okay
um because that was the information I
was able to get uh
and uh I want you to know that if you
look at uh you look at 167 per megawatt
hour or even 102 dollars per megawatt
hour our grid usually runs 20 to 80
dollars per megawatt hour
okay so these are very high prices now
sometimes our grid runs a lot higher
than that I don't want to kid you and
real crunches it can run a lot higher uh
recently last Christmas it was a two
thousand dollars per megawatt hour but
nevertheless for uh for ongoing work not
you know here we're in a crisis
um a hundred and two to 167 is is a lot
of money luckily you won't pay that
money per se because it'll be mixed in
with inexpensive money from other uh
um other operators unless of course
it ends up setting the clearing price
and I don't know that I don't know if it
okay then this is a local code grid
batteries now uh I I don't have a lot of
cost information for Batteries actually
I don't think I have any but the thing
is that the biggest Landing battery in
the world at this point according to
um uh energy storage news uh is the
battery at Moss Landing and it has 750
megawatts of storage and four hours that
it can discharge
um
this is not backing up the grid the Grid
at base load is 10 000 megawatts okay
and I just want to say that Vermont
Yankee which was 620 megawatts and could
run for 18 months without refueling was
considered to be too small to be cost
effective Meanwhile we're looking at
these batteries that can run for four
hours now they're good for many things
you know if there's a some kind of
terrible problem with one plant they
could really save the day but
people have a tendency to look at them
okay
so here's another so far I've been
trying to stick to just the facts let me
just say that I I have opinions and I
think the nuclear could be a really good
base load remember base load 60 70
percent of energy we get nuclear as our
base load we're going to have very low
CO2 emissions
okay because we're only going to have 40
to 4 30 to 40 percent to play with with
with fossil plans
uh nuclear can be sized to the grid now
what do I mean by that uh okay nuclear
stores fuel on site you already got that
part
um
in the old days the when grids were
designed okay when and and
designed to be reliable the rule of
thumb was that whatever your Peak demand
was you kept a hundred and twenty
percent of power plants available to
meet that demand 120 percent of that
demand in power plants that you had
available okay that meant that if your
Peak demand was wrong or a power plant
or two went offline you could still do
it
now
in those days
nuclear
or any plant
uh was no more than 10 percent of the
grid it was not supposed to be 10 of the
Grid or more than 10 percent of the grid
so you have the giant Palo Verde plant
nuclear plant out in Arizona oddly
enough it supplies Phoenix and uh nla it
isn't more than 10 percent of the grid
you look at those cities
solar acts like a mega plant it may be
all dispersed it's distributed it's
wonderful but when you get right down
from the Sun goes down it all goes away
and similarly if you remember the
picture I showed you of uh the fun and
games on the Texas grid there are 40
percent
um 40 solar I mean 40 megawatts is what
20 what I can't remember it now but what
I'm trying to say is the equivalent of
our entire grid went away when the wind
died down in Texas it was 20 megawatts
20 gigawatts
ah
but anyway
um but you see the thing is that to some
extent
the Renewables are like uh giant plants
you know it's it always uh it's sunny or
it isn't
and I just want to say that nuclear can
follow a load
and if you we were willing right now
we're running on over 50 natural gas in
New England that's what we have so
anybody who's concerned about well how
are we going to get the last 10 percent
I say hey how about the first 50 you
know so if we had nuclear base loaded 60
we would we would not have to have
nearly as much fossil and and you say
well you might still have to have some
fossil I'm like okay I agree
but uh I don't I mean I'm just sort of
like whatever
so I just want to say uh another thing
again editorializing
the conventional statements are often
about how an individual citizen is
supposed to act
make personal sacrifices don't eat meat
don't keep your house too warm
uh don't uh lawnmowers why don't you
have a wild lawn plastic straws it's all
up to me and and it's like I'm gonna do
this I'm going to change my way of
living and everything's going to be
great
but I want to say that and and you all
know this because you're all
Representatives you are all here making
regulations laws rules
a citizen is a citizen not a loan actor
a good citizen acts as a citizen and
realizes the death toll if anything
happens to the grid there are 200 to 700
people who died in Texas just from a
48-hour outage if you read and I don't
recommend you to read it before bedtime
Ted koppel's old book life's out about
what would happen if the American grid
went down but don't read it before
bedtime I'm telling you it's a scary
book
so let's have uh we I want to
see us making choices
that will lead to a stable reliable Grid
it's not about sacrifices it's about
choices it can be also about sacrifices
it may be that we should keep our houses
cooler but that isn't it I mean
everybody in Germany that's right now
using a lot of lignite okay lots of
lignite coal they could all keep their
houses cooler and they still wouldn't
so anyway this is about my book and uh I
didn't read copies but I guess there's a
copy floating around and uh I would like
you to I'm happy to hear from you and
you can write me at
Meredith Anglin at gmail just all squish
together one word on the formerly known
as Twitter I'm at Meredith anguin and
there's a uh there's a very nice thing
called uh electricitymaps.com you gotta
fuss around a little bit with it but
it's a it's very good to show you which
grids are actually producing a lot of
CO2 and that's it well thank you that
I'm gonna I'm gonna put you on the spot
a little bit and ask you if you can help
us resolve a question that we debate on
this committee quite frequently
it's about
transmission costs you write in your
book the building of distributed
Generations smaller power plants such as
solar arrays increases the cost of
transmission
renewable Advocates will disagree with
this statement
indeed if Renewables were always
available to be dispatched to the grid
this statement would be false however
since most Renewables are available only
part of the time they must be backed up
with other forms of power therefore
transmission costs do increase and you
emphasize the word do in your text
now this committee debates this question
frequently
if a renewable system is on the grid
then the people who consume the
electricity near that system avoid
transmission costs yes theoretically
so the question always becomes
do Renewables increase or decrease
transmission costs you've asserted that
they increase them could you give us
some insight as to your reasoning and
try to help us resolve this question
well yes first of all you have the
Renewables are um
are often built where people don't live
now I am I'm a fan of a relative fan of
rooftop solar uh what because a solar
the thing about solar is it's available
when people need power wind it's when
it's available and it isn't got anything
to do with the people in Nepal
so what I'm saying is that a wind
turbines are built
where it's windy
and people aren't living there
so for example let's say I I say to you
uh
there's a a nuclear plant here and we're
shutting it down and we're going to
replace it with
no there's a coal plant here and we're
shutting it down we're going to replace
it with
well if you replaced it with a nuclear
plant you could use the same footprint
you could use the same transmission
lines you could use the same
substations you you you don't have extra
cost except the usual costs of upgrading
systems that you have to do all the time
anyway okay I mean it you don't have to
build anything new you don't have to you
don't have to send people out to do uh
Scouting For who's going to be least
offended if we put a transmission line
here and so forth okay
but if you decide that you're going to
replace it with uh wind backed up by
natural gas
well the natural gas might be in place
where you already have transmission
lines it might it might not I don't know
I can't say that
but the wind isn't going to be
the wind is going to be on a ridge or
out to sea or whatever and you're going
to have to have transmission lines and
substations that are
um I you know one of the problems with
talking about the grid
is that I want to be authoritative on
every subject and I'm moderately
authoritative on many subjects but for
example I'm giving a course at osher
and and the OSHA course I have invited
Lee cordner whose business is helping
people build transmission lines and he's
going to be a guest speaker I wish I
could kind of pull him over here and and
and and and and have him here I can't I
for one think he lives in in uh in um uh
in California and he's going to be on
zoom and for other other things he's
actually kind of shy about having things
recorded and so forth because he's
involved in so many actual issues but
basically that is one of the things and
then once you get those transmission
lines to the wind turbines they're only
available 30 percent of the time so
usually if you build a lot of
transmission lines like the ones that
were streaming out from uh Seabrook all
the ones leading out from Seabrook you
expect to have a power on the large part
of the timer isn't worth investing so
you end up with a lot of expense
yeah okay thank you representative
Thomas has a question
uh thank you Mr chairman for and thank
you for taking my question
um so you mentioned three types of grids
and but you haven't I have not had the
opportunity to treat your book you did
not mention grid modernization and how
does that how would you say that fits
into uh the trend of wanting to put more
Renewables out there but people do
realize that we have to have grid
modernization how does that affect
um that and I like to add first I forgot
to say thank you very much for a most
pragmatic presentation which I really
enjoy so thank you for that and that now
my question okay
so the question is about grid
modernization unfortunately grid
modernization covers a lot of ground
some of which I think is lovely and some
of which I think is terrible so uh or at
least not too good
I hate to say terrible so some of the
good
good things about grid modernization is
that you with with uh with a modern grid
the um
the uh
grid operator doesn't have to wait for
the phone calls to come in to say oh my
God I just lost power and a tree is down
about three blocks from here
they know where the power failed because
the the grid is now a little bit more uh
give some more information
on the other hand a lot of grid
well it's it's it's going to lead to
more expense for what I don't consider
to be
a worth very worthwhile
results
so for example let's say we begin
charging our electric vehicles at night
well I've been reading I didn't even
know this until a couple weeks ago but
apparently our
our Transformers
expect to cool down at night and if all
of a sudden they're not cooling down
they're going to shorten their life
expectancy so are we happy because we
have just modernized a grid we've
replaced a bunch of Transformers with
bigger Transformers that maybe are big
enough so that even if people are
charging at night they're still cooling
down I don't know but what I'm trying to
say is or another thing
um
I am not
a fan I I mean I think it's fine
for a big company to decide that it's
going to participate in a demand
response program because it's worth it
to that uh company to have lower
electric rates because they're in the
program even if every two years there or
ever whatever their their turn they have
to turn off their electricity that's the
company's decision whether they're going
to make them that or not
I feel that the modern grid is forcing
us all into demand response programs I
mean I have a friend in California
who wrote me and she said you know I'm a
working single mother Meredith and I
come home and I turn on uh the stove and
I cook dinner for my kids don't judge me
I said who am I to judge you but what
I'm trying to say is that she's not
supposed to do that it's a flex alert
time the flex alert lasts from four
o'clock to nine o'clock and you're
supposed to minimize the amount of
electricity you use
so I don't know what good modernization
means
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here really appreciated your
presentation
um my question is around capacity
planning because when I first started
paying attention to the iso New England
and the planning that's being done it
seems like our energy systems are
extremely siled and so the
responsibility for reliability may be
the ballywick of the iso but the idea
around what we put on or take off the
grid in terms of reliability we've had a
lot of nuclear plants that have closed
rather than upgrading them to new
technology that could load follow you
know it doesn't seem like there's any
planning in terms of the actual problems
that we're going to be facing in the
future
and so the question really is around
where the responsibility lies for that
capacity planning in terms of like you
said the decisions that get made because
that's the reason I'm here is that I I
thought that the the most important
decisions the state would be making
would be around
uh you know what what we would be doing
with the grid for the future and how it
would be very expensive for people if we
make the wrong decisions right if we run
down the wrong roads we're going to
spend a lot of time and a lot of money
uh undoing those those runs in the wrong
direction
well I agree with you and I've often
said that the trouble with the RTO
system is the buck stops nowhere uh if
uh and and it has a a market independent
Market monitor who's supposed to uh look
and see if for example some some
company owns three power plants on the
grid and it sees that the grid is having
a problem and it takes one of its power
plants off because now the the grid
operator is going to have to call in
very expensive power plants and now it's
going to make more money it's not going
to have to supply fuel for its cheapest
power plant and it's going to make more
money so this and and then
so the the grid uh independent Market
monitor is supposed to be on the lookout
for this but I tell you I don't think
that they can watch it all I mean and
what I mean by that is that uh I read a
really good book not on the same subject
it's Javier Blas is uh the world for
sale about Traders and I can tell you
that no matter what the monitors say the
Traders will get their trades done and
similarly if there's a company that
wants uh to get the uh the clearing
price higher and it can do it it will
manage to do it I mean I don't mean to
be terribly cynical but anyway
that's how I look at the world I guess
that's me I'm cynical
um but yes the buck doesn't stop
anywhere one other thing about the buck
not stopping if you go to ISO New
England and you say um
where are the power plants that you
should be building power the iso New
England will say resource adequacy is
the state's business how many power
plants are built it's a state's business
we just dispatched them I'm like huh
you you also set up the rules for who
gets paid how much that's a little bit
of a responsibility but anyway that is
something I wanted to say Okay I I I've
talked too long yes representative munz
has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for uh
coming in I'd like to come back to the
conversation we were having we were
having with you about transmission costs
um and I I will I will accept you know
your premise that if you were to replace
a coal-fired plant with a nuclear plant
you wouldn't have to build new
transmission lines I completely agree
with you there
um and and I would also agree that if
you
um install wind turbines offshore you're
going to have to build new transmission
lines so there's going to be a
transmission cost increase but isn't
that only half the equation because the
cost of actually produce a building the
wind turbines
is going to be significantly less than
the cost of building a nuclear plant no
um
um and and the ongoing operating costs
for example or a solar farm
um I mean you know yes I mean maybe the
transmission costs go up but don't we
have to look at the total costs actually
we've been there's been a lot of work on
that and I don't follow it as close as I
should but basically what happened is
back in the day uh Lazar Brothers used
to write a thing called the levelized
cost of transmission for different uh
different types of power plants and and
and and and and and it was always coming
out with you know oh solar uh wind is
great well people began saying hey we
put wind on a grid and and uh almost
always the uh the cost of to the
consumer goes up and so Lazar has
recently gone back and and then other
people were doing calculations on what
they call system costs that is you put
the wind on the grid and then uh you
have to make sure there's uh gas plants
on the grid and also when a nuclear
plant runs for 40 40 uh years no problem
60 years no problem I don't know if it's
going to run 80 years but what I'm
trying to say is your average wind
turbine is restructured after 10 years
now the reason for that is a little more
complicated this is the whole policy
thing but basically wind turbines get
what's called a uh production tax credit
which runs out after 10 years but they
can reset the clock by doing a major
overhaul so I don't really know whether
they could last 20 years if if they if
the product production tax credit lasted
20 years it's the policy and the
physical are very confusing but I would
say that a wind turbine is is out there
in the wind in the atmosphere it's a
delicate piece of equipment and it
really isn't going to last for 60 years
and so you have to look at that a
follow-up and I always use I was only
using wind as an example of of a
renewable uh fuel I mean
um you know solars and other Renewable
Fuel my point is that
um
to argue that
that renew that Renewables are going to
drive up the cost of transmission
therefore they are not worth investing
in doesn't seem to hold water
because there are because the the the
the the the the the the the the the
capital cost and perhaps and and
certainly the operating costs of some of
these renewable projects is going to be
a lot less
the capital cost if you look at running
a a renewable project for 40 years and
replacing it after 10 to 20 years is not
as per megawatt hour it's not not as low
as you might think okay and and I I
encourage you to look at lassit brothers
and a Tom Stacy who does a lot of work
on that uh and um
I didn't say they weren't worth building
I mean I think that I I personally think
that a nuclear base load plus uh uh
solar and natural gas following would be
a lovely lovely uh low low carbon uh
low-cost grid but I'm going to tell you
right now that I am remember the first
slide reliability is first reliability
is first I'm sorry I should I should I
wish I had some kind of deep voice and
something bang on but but basically
reliability is first and and and wind
turbines may have zero fuel costs but
that you can't count on them when the
going gets tough
okay representative Harrington gets the
last question and then we have to wrap
up uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question it was very
informative presentation try to get a
little bit out of the theoretical and
maybe a little bit more into the
Practical I don't know how versed you
are in this but if you do have an
opinion I'd like to hear it the the two
Mystic power plants are going to be
closing next June they're basically the
RMR plans right now that won't be
extended they've already announced that
they're going to close down that's 1400
megawatts of power we're going to lose
but because they take about 60 percent
of the offload from the Everett LNG
facility it looks like the Everett LNG
facility is also going to close now I
was recently at a ferc ISO New England
winter assessment meeting and looking
forward and about half the people there
said we've got to do something to keep
the Everett LNG facility going because
we don't have enough natural gas in the
winter and we also need it for back
pressure on the natural gas pipelines
and the other half said no we can
probably get away without it do you have
an opinion when way the other on that I
wish we were keeping them yes I mean I
I'm sorry but but there's a lot of
wishful thinking about we can probably
get away you understand that a a a a a
systems engineer shouldn't be saying
that
I mean that's not the the the best way
now I understand that people really
really don't like them and and and as a
matter of fact uh uh I I think it's uh
it's sort of shameful that we have to
get LNG cargos from Tobago to run our
grid
I mean I think that's a shame and I
think somebody should go over to New
York and shake them until they let us
build a pipeline to the Marcellus
but uh I I just want to say that I I was
I watched that meeting also I I have to
tell you that I don't travel as much as
I'd I'd like to so I watch a lot of
meetings on on Zoom
and that's the way it is I just tell
people in the wintertime especially when
you go home at night pray that there's
no industrial accidents in Tobago
because if there is we're out of luck
for a big
Rich industrial country to be dependent
this way
I agree and thank you very much for your
presentation here today it's really been
a treat to have you here and we're
really grateful that you came and we
hope to see you again sometime thank you
thank you
we are officially on lunch break now
until one o'clock at which time we will
take up our retained bills so we'll see
okay everybody please take your seat
yeah my car's outside it's smashed
well you got whiplash on we're getting
your ended all right everybody let's get
started
this is the one o'clock session of
science technology and energy we are
going to have a full committee work
session on our retained bills
and here's what we're going to do we're
going to go through each bill
one by one
and we're going to decide whether or not
we need to form a subcommittee
if the answer is no then we move on to
the next bill
if the answer is yes then we form a
subcommittee we ask for volunteers to
serve on the subcommittee and I appoint
the chair of the subcommittee will then
go to the subcommittee members and
discuss potential future meeting dates
once you decide on potential future
meeting dates then the chair will go to
carry
our admin and the staff office to
now the presence of members of a
subcommittee is required at a
subcommittee meeting
but any stne member or in fact any
member of the House can attend a
subcommittee meeting
according to House Rules
the subcommittee will then deliberate
on
what should happen with the bill
if it's decided by the subcommittee that
a that an amendment is necessary or
desirable for the bill the subcommittee
will
create such an amendment
and bring it to the full committee when
we convene to pass judgment on all of
so that will be the procedure
and hopefully we can get through these
12 bills fairly promptly anybody have
any questions about the procedure
representative Gorman thank you I just
want to verify are you planning that we
would do an exec on all 12 bills on
October 31st
not
October 31st but uh a day to be
determined later and and we would exec
all 12 together all 12 will be done on
the same day yes
okay let's get started first bill is
I suggest that since this bill is
unconstitutional as written
that we consider itl as the motion for
this bill
now I know some people
would expect that we would want to try
to do something about the spiking cost
of energy
and representative Bernardi has filed a
bill
for this uh or an LSR for this upcoming
session
to allow laddering of
default service procurement so
representative Bernardi could you
the LSR is not yet written uh completely
it's in it's with OLS how however the
concept that I gave them was uh right
now we have contract requirements that
go every six months and when the when
the utilities go out looking to fill
those contracts they're subject to
largely the the costs that are available
in the market in that unique time window
um with the lattering concept they could
have uh
contracts that go anywhere from I I
suggested three to nine month period and
um and I asked OLS to look at other
states how they're doing it and so we
could use those as examples uh in in
preparing that language so that's that's
representative Harrington in the past
that's was that was how the rates were
set there used to be like Unitil or
whatever would have a contract and it
would have half of their load for a
certain period another absolutely all
the load would not come up due on the
same date like they they are now so
there is a precedent for doing this so
I'm sure if we look back we could figure
out how it was done
you're dealing with averages so it all
depends sometimes it's going to come out
beneficial sometimes it isn't it's like
if you looked at this past year when
Maine does it on a yearly basis we do it
on six months ours went up higher and
everyone oh my God the price is much
lower in Maine but then when the prices
went down and we were able to adjust
quicker no one made a big deal out of
the fact that the prices were going to
be higher in Maine for the next six
months so it's I mean it it minimizes
the ups and downs but it probably
doesn't change the total cost very much
it just means you're paying you know x
amount of dollars more closer to the
same amount every month rather than have
it go up
120 percent of accident go down to 80 of
X so I don't think it changes the totals
that much but it does make it avoids
those big bumps and bills
representative Thomas thank you Mr yeah
I want to uh reiterate with
representative Harrington said I think
the key is that the lattering can
soften the blow shall we speak it it
it's uh so that people have a more
consistent monthly payment versus
getting shocked
every so often so to me I think that's
an advantage people at least have a good
expectation of uh pretty close to what
they might be paying every month except
being surprised with big jumps and so
forth so so if the purpose of the
original bill hb159 was to average
default service costs I think it was
five years representative Mickey
Williams
yes the intent of the original bill was
to allow up to five years to and this
was as amended it was attempted to be
amended the day it was presented uh
there was an issue where this committee
did not allow amendments the day it was
presented but that was the presented
amendment was laddering up to five years
so therefore your term could be very
short say two months three months or it
could be a five year to create a pie
chart mix where you have some very risky
and some very not risky investments in
long-term and short-term together which
as representative Thomas acknowledged
then therefore averages out the overall
cost and we don't have surprises for our
constituents who receive a bill in the
winter that is just crazy expensive
so it is an averaging Bill and as
representative Harrington just explained
laddering is also an averaging technique
so the question then becomes
should we go with the laddering bill and
either
interim study or itl this bill or take
another path
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman
um well I think our recommendation would
be that we ought to pass as amended the
bill that was submitted under hb159 but
you had alluded when you opened uh the
session that that the bill was somehow
unconstitutional
um and I thought maybe you could speak
to that piece of why you have exception
to the bill and I didn't know whether
you were talking about the bill
in its original form or as amended
I think I was talking about the bill in
its original form
and I recall and he can correct me if
I'm wrong that Mr locata from eversource
testified that averaging over five years
would deprive the utility of the ability
to recover its costs in any given year
potentially which would be a violation
of the takings Clause of the
thank you uh yeah yes that is correct
the issue becomes when the cost that the
utility incurs by procuring the power is
different than the cost that the utility
is allowed to recover so if it's again
just speaking to the original Bill if it
was a five-year average of regional
rates
let's say that was 10 cents but the
utility went out to purchase the power
from the market and let's say that was
12 cents essentially the utility is
unable to recover the cost that it
incurred uh to provide service to the
customer so uh as uh chairman vo said uh
that would constitute a taking under the
the Constitution
okay thank you very much
okay
representative McWilliams just be clear
I'm advocating for the amendment the 159
as amended I think we all agree that
there were issues with the underlying
bill but I think that there is something
here that's worth working on with the
amendment certainly for laddering and it
sounds like representative Bernardi has
already put something into OLS to start
the process for next year so having a
working group now might be a really good
idea because we could have a nice
bipartisan discussion about all of these
options and perhaps even weigh in on the
proposed legislation before it's
finalized with OLS so we can have a
really good bipartisan consensus coming
into Lottery for January rather than
waiting until January to see what OLS
drafts and then having to create a
subcommittee within this committee
February March to do the same thing that
we could do now in the next couple of
weeks so what I'm proposing is we go
with the amendment and even if we vote
Yes or no we'll still have the
opportunity to work together on
laddering now
thank you okay so can you refresh our
memory about what the amendment contains
because I just looked in the folder and
there is no copy of the amendment in the
folder
Mr chairman while she's looking at that
I just want to make one other comment on
this
um go ahead the bill I don't know if the
amendment addresses this but this talks
for using the five-year average of
retail rates from the New England region
which would mean it would be based on
things that are happening outside of New
Hampshire which we have no control over
I'm not sure I want to be allowing
things that Rhode Island does to set the
electric rates in New Hampshire because
they could do things that would drive up
the retail cost but maybe at the
advantage of the people in Rhode Island
but nothing to New Hampshire so I think
that's another issue here and also
there's been a lot of discussion lately
over looking at
a different way of procuring completely
like going to the market sort of like
the way the uh the co-op does or some
modification of that and I think there's
a report coming out of Des in I believe
it's December the beginning end of
December they're supposed to address
that because there was a preliminary
study done by the puc they said if you
looked back over the last five years I
think they went back two five-year
groups and you looked at what the actual
lmps were as a basis and compared to
getting contracts you would have saved
money going that direction so that's
another thing that could be considered
in this upcoming bill as well
representative McWilliams
that five-year piece was proposed with
the original Bill not the amended Bill
the amended bill doesn't look to other
states the amended bill is just about
New Hampshire
yeah um so
so what I'm proposing is we put together
a subcommittee to talk about laddering
because I think it's important that
everyone who's concerned about electric
rates and laddering have an opportunity
to discuss that and potentially have
some input on this proposed bill for
next year
the timing is right I'm not saying that
I want to pass the amended bill but I'm
also saying let's not throw out the baby
with the bath water and wait another six
months before we address this so my
proposal is let's have a subcommittee
let's talk let's come up with some
recommended best practices and whether
the recommendation from the subcommittee
is yes we love what we talked about
let's pass it as further amended or no I
don't think this bill will work but
we're going to come up with something
excellent that can work for next year I
think the timing right now makes sense
for us to have a subcommittee to work on
it and that's what I'm pitching it's not
about original 159 it's not even about
159 as amended with the language related
to uh
related to New Hampshire's wholesale
Market which is a very
it's a very broad term about New
Hampshire but it doesn't relate to Rhode
Island or any other state
um I think really what we want to do is
just have some good fact finding now so
that we can be prepared for when we
start again as a committee in January
and that's my pitch that's really what I
think we want to do as responsible
legislators to our constituents and to
the Electric market as it is let's bring
in some experts have really good
testimony let's discuss pros and cons
and let's come up with a strategy for
laddering for next year's Bill thank you
2023.0557h as in horse
yep
any further comment on whether or not we
should form a subcommittee for
researching this issue
representative nodder
thank you Mr chairman with our limited
time and so many bills to consider I
think it's better to start to start with
a clean bill in January than an amended
one
seeing none uh
I'm okay with forming a subcommittee to
study this question
do we have volunteers I need at least
three
anybody else
all right I think that's enough members
of that subcommittee I will appoint
representative Bernardi to be the chair
of that committee and you guys can
get together and figure out when you
want to start meeting and just recall or
remember that we'll need to have you'll
need to wrap up your work
on or before October 31st
the executive session will probably be
in early November
I'll have to look at the House calendar
to be sure exactly when our final date
for dealing with this issue is but
okay next is HB 166 relative to the
elimination of useful thermal energy
I think the recommendation for this bill
is itl does anyone have any further
comments on it representative Harrington
yeah I realize this bill isn't going
anywhere but it's I guess might call it
my pet peeve we want I think the people
of New Hampshire let rate pays should
know what they're paying for and paying
for somebody to heat a factory that has
nothing to do with electric rates
shouldn't be subsidized by the electric
rate payers but it is I realize it's not
going to pass just itl it and I just
request don't put it on consent
okay
seeing none
we will move on to House Bill 175
relative to the state's energy
consumption goal
once again this bill has come before us
before and didn't gain any traction
I suspect itl might be the best way to
that's the bill where you changed the
word
fossil fuels to greenhouse gases this
was requested at one time by the
department of energy I even heard much
back from him on it so I guess it's not
okay
moving on
HP 176 relative to the rules of the site
evaluation committee
pardon
yeah we're gonna well
we haven't taken a formal vote but the
recommendation is itl at this point
um
HB 176 relative to the rules of the site
evaluation committee representative
Harrington you have a comment
uh
this is a what is it 176 I don't have it
from me I believe this is the one that
basically says make the rules fit the
law and I'd like to see this go forward
there was uh five or six years ago maybe
longer than that now there was a bill
passed that put a lot of additional
restrictions on wind power it was right
after the antrum wind projects and the
law basically said these apply to win
projects and when they wrote the rules
at the puc at the time put those uh put
those uh restrictions and requirements
on all energy projects uh and that
simply was overstretched what they did I
wasn't in the house at the time nor on
the puc I tried to get involved and was
basically told by a senator on gel car
no one knows what they're talking about
anyways we're not going to waste any
more time on this we're passing the
rules as is so this would simply say and
I guess it would probably be directed
back to the Department of energy now go
fix the rules to match the law and it's
pretty straightforward I would think
everyone would be in favor of not
allowing uh
agencies like the puc to create
legislation they should Implement what's
passed by this house
representative McGee yeah well I
appreciate the explanation from
representative Harrington I think that
sounds
vague being put asking doe to
modify the rules to fit the law and so I
think the if that bill were to go
forward it would require I think uh more
specific instruction from us in terms of
what is intended because it seems like
there are a lot of other things that
could be
ratified under something that's as vague
as that so I I would still be in favor
of itl if I could respond Mr chairman
yes
in the bill directly it says in order to
amend the rules pursuant to section one
of this the committee shall include but
not limited to the following and like
site rule the specific rule requiring
the committee to conduct an adjunitive
hearing again blah blah blah and then it
says another site Rule 30105 and then on
the site rule 30108 in site rule 30108
C4 so it's very specific we list the
different places where they have to
change the rules does it not does it say
what they are it's it lists the rule
right right in the bill and you can go
to the thing it says it says this
requires all energy facilities to have
an emergency response plan there is no
such requirement in RSA 162h they just
made it up
so it's very specific in the bill
to follow up on representative McGee's
question
starting on line three of the bill it
says
no later than 60 days after the
effective date of this paragraph the
committee shall initiate a proceeding to
amend adopted rules site 100 through
site 300.
to ensure that no Authority is assumed
to the committee that is not
specifically authorized by RSA 162-h
but then section two only mentions one
two three four specific rules
all in in the 301 section of the rules
so I think the reason this bill didn't
get traction earlier representative
Harrington is because it it seems to be
directing
the site evaluation committee to do an a
review of rules
that's
quite extensive
even though the bill only wants it to
look at four specific rules
is there a way to tighten it up and and
make are these the only four rules you
think need to be reviewed well it says
the shall include but not limited to I
could live with just having it do these
these four ones so they're certainly
better than having none because uh you
know having these things like an
emergency response plan for a solar
facility is kind of ridiculous it was
never the intent of the law we have
trouble enough citing things in New
Hampshire and putting make having
committees make up requirements that
so would the committee be open to
restrict the site evaluation committee
rules review to just the four rules
no comment
well it would obviously mean that the
site evaluation committee administrator
who happens to be in the room would
probably have to take on this
responsibility or at least to guide the
representative Bernardi
thank you Mr chair I think the the
administrator could
readily take on the four identified
items and propose those to the a full
committee and the next time they met and
and address this issue I agree that if
it's expansive going through sections
100 through 300 and everything contained
so representative Harrington would you
be willing to create an amendment to
restrict the bill to just those four
sure you just have to take out a few
words there's no problem with that okay
so going forward then it looks like what
we will do with HB 176 is
otpa unless there is further comment on
and representative Harrington will
prepare
an amendment on this bill okay good
next is Mississippi can we make sure
that's circulated before we have the
exact
excuse me the amendment can we just make
sure it's circulated before we have the
exact so we don't have to learn about it
there good suggestion representative
Harrington could you circulate that
Amendment sooner rather than later
thank you
okay HB 381 relative to solar generation
under the renewable portfolio standards
this is a bill that kind of undoes what
HB 549 did
I'm not sure it would gain much traction
I suggest itl any further Mr chairman
representative Harrington I'm a little
confused I've got HB 381 relative to
solar generation and renewable portfolio
standards then on the other list over
here I've got HP 381 relative to system
benefits charge
so is it just two different names for
yes you're right it is relative to the
and this has to do with whether it can
be changed with uh by the puc or some
other one would require that but my
original comment still applies that this
bill essentially undoes what HB 549 did
and didn't seem to gain much traction
within the committee its first time
around but what is HP the one you just
you see the language that on starting on
line eight all the way down to line 16
that has been struck out that's language
HB 549 it had added a lot more language
to statute but that language is
uh essentially The crucial part
of the bill and what it created and
established
all right I guess this is getting no way
so let's just get rid of it
okay so we'll probably go with itl on
next is HB 548 relative to participation
in net energy metering by small
hydroelectric generators
this bill was identical to Senate Bill
40 which we passed and the governor has
signed into law so this bill is no
longer necessary so I recommend itl any
seeing none
next is hb509 relative to phasing out
the minimal electric renewable portfolio
standard
this bill has written
uh
calls for a
phase out of the RPS by 2028 I believe
but it presents us with an opportunity
to create a study committee to determine
what's going to happen with the RPS
after 2025 because right now as written
the RPS statute kind of stagnates in
2025.
and
2025 although it may have seemed at one
time to be a long way into the future is
not that far away
so
I'm of the opinion that we might want to
use this bill as a vehicle to just to
study
what's next for the renewable portfolio
standard now that may be too much of a
job for a study committee that can only
meet for two or three weeks
but it could result in a an amendment to
this bill
that essentially says
let's form a study committee
to see what happens to the RPS after
2025.
representative Harrington you know the
intent of this bill was as just like it
says is to phase it out for those who
weren't around when the RPS came out it
was it was we needed to give the
renewable energy a boost to get it going
because it was a you know in an
infantile uh
method of producing electricity and it
needed to help to get going and
eventually That was supposed to be was
never supposed to be permanent it was
once was up and running we've certainly
seen a number of uh solar and wind
projects and other Renewables now we
also have the production tax credits uh
uh and the investment tax credits which
have been extended for probably forever
under the crazy bills passed by Congress
so my intent on this is was how long do
we got to keep giving this holding up
the hand of the Renewables I think it
should be phased out especially with all
the federal tax breaks they're getting
so that was the intent of the bill
representative Kaplan
yeah I can understand the uh the uh the
feeling for the need for uh eventual
looking at the continued sub subsidy of
Renewables I mean it's
you know it was implemented with the
idea that it would that this infantile
industry as you said would need a would
need some sort of boost and it does it
still need that boost I think it's an
open question it's an interesting
question I don't think we're ready to
answer that question as as a committee
here and if we wanted to to deal with
that issue we would really need to look
at it in depth and in you know a
long-term study so um I think I agree
with the the chairman I think that it it
warrants a study committee but I don't
agree with the intent of the underlying
bill that we would be studying because I
don't think we're ready to declare that
the RPS is in need of elimination so
um I don't know where that leaves me but
I I am in favor of looking at it as a
study committee
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman I think in in our conversations
as well I mentioned to you that
currently this committee asks that the
department of energy provide us with a
report on on the status of the RPS each
year in October I believe it is and we
um don't do a lot with that information
that we receive already right we don't
make an assessment of whether the RPS is
work operating as we would like it to or
if we're meeting our goals or should
increase our goals or lower our goals or
I mean nobody lowers their goals because
that's the point of the RPS is to really
measure what you're doing in terms of
penetration of various types of clean
energy but
um I think that
we should probably make an effort to
look at the information that we already
have and absorb that before we go
forward with trying to certainly not
eliminate it I mean we would have to
have a good reason to eliminate it and I
don't think the fact that there are
federal subsidies trying to help people
figure out how to implement cleaner
sources I don't think that that's a
reason for us to do away with a program
that basically is designed to help us
keep track of what we're doing in those
sectors and make it easier for doe for
example to measure how we're doing in
those sectors if we take away the RPS
then the measurement goes away
so I I'm opposed to uh moving forward
with it I'm not opposed to a interim
study on it but
um I think itl is probably appropriate
and if we are going to look at the RPS I
believe you Mr chairman have filed
something on the RPS
in the LSR system so I think we'll have
an opportunity to look at it further in
the coming year but I don't think we
since you brought it up I will mention
that I have filed an LSR to change the
renewable portfolio standard to a clean
energy portfolio standard
because I wanted to start that
conversation so I have filed a bill to
give us an opportunity to do that
representative Harrington did you have
something else yeah I just uh I don't
want to stretch out a big argument on
this thing but you know my point is that
this was never supposed to be a
permanent subsidy to people and it's
also I don't think you can pick up a
paper or if anyone picks up papers
anymore or put on the Internet or watch
the television whatever without being
constantly bombarded but we're all going
to die from global warming in a couple
of weeks so everybody in New Hampshire
knows about global warming and carbon
emission and zero based and all this so
the fact then comes down to we consider
them too stupid to make that decision on
what type of electricity to buy because
if they're all worried about global
warming they'll all go out and buy
renewable energy you can go to the puc
website and you can select someone to
give you 100 wind or wind and solar or
whatever else and all I'm saying is I
think people in New Hampshire are smart
enough to make that decision they're no
longer ignorant of the problem because
they've certainly been inundated with it
and we shouldn't as the state be saying
you are too dumb to pick out the type of
electricity you want so we're going to
pick it out for you and force you to buy
something that you don't necessarily
want
so we have this uh
kind of a
conflict
with regard to the bills we're
discussing here
when we talked about hb159 we talked
about trying to
do something about the high cost of
energy
and yet
on page 233 of Meredith's
anguin's book
she cited
information from a 2015 study by energy
tariff experts
which revealed that
renewable portfolio standards in New
England costs varied from two to three
cents per kilowatt hour in Maine to 1.1
to 1.6 cents per kilowatt hour in
Massachusetts with other states falling
in between
she goes on to further State the rate
payers nobody calls us customers pay
these overhead expenses the price Rises
caused by renewable portfolio standards
are significant those are her words so
here we are talking about trying to
bring down the cost of energy
but we've got a program here that
actually drives up the cost of energy
so I'm wondering if there is some way we
can reconcile those two conflicting
I think reconciling them is essential
what we're here for however I would at
this time suggest that forward rather
than uh try to turn this bill into
something and it's not and just give
representative Kaplan
yeah I think this conversation is is
quickly smiled Way Beyond the scope of
the the build that we're supposed to be
discussing so uh before I go I agree
with the representative Parson before go
any further we should just itl it
representative Harrington I I don't
think the bill is going to go forward
again I just want to let the board out
to the people of New Hampshire of what
they're paying for on the electric bill
I have no problem with itl as long as it
doesn't go on the consent calendar
representative lewicki
no
representative McGee
yeah I my comment was really just a
comment that you made about sort of that
there's a cost to the RPS it's there's
also a benefit to the RPS which is the
reason that we're doing it and so the
you know those are the kind of
conversations we can have when your bill
comes around but since this bill's
premise is to phase out the RPS I I
think we should just let it go we're not
we're not going to agree that that's
um
something we want to do right now with
the retained bill
to pass that into law
what was the decision on that is it Ito
we're not going to form a study
subcommittee I mean okay and then we'll
discuss the outcome of the bill and
executive session
next is
hb558 relative to micro grids and
electric grid resiliency
now I know that the prime sponsor of
this bill who is Representative Keith
Ammon has been working with the
Department of energy and the utilities
to come up with some amendments to the
bill
and
apparently from what I've heard I was
hoping representative Ammon might be
here today but he's not so from what
I've heard
the amendment language May address the
concerns of both the doe and the
department of energy so the question is
should we form a subcommittee to study
the amendment which I'm sure we can get
a copy of
promptly or should we just wait until we
see the amendment and then decide what
to do
thoughts
representative Thomas I think Mr when
are we expecting to see the amendment
I don't know the answer to that
representative McWilliams
thank you chervos um
speaking as an engineer and someone who
thinks linearly and also with a little
bit of strategy I think it makes all the
sense in the world to form a
subcommittee and if we can't get a copy
of the amendment just don't meet but the
alternative is the amendment is still
under discussion and we don't form a
subcommittee so the first time we see
the amendment is when we're voting just
before October 31st I think
strategically it probably makes more
sense to form a subcommittee that may or
may not meet thank you Mr chair
additional comments representative Wendy
Thomas representative McWilliams has
further comments
I'm okay with forming a subcommittee who
wants to be on a micro grid subcommittee
please raise your hand
representative Wendy Thomas and
representative Douglas Thomas
anybody else
oops
okay so we have
Doug Thomas Wendy Thomas Tom closure and
Kat McGee alaport Point Doug Thomas to
okay
it's only four people that's all who
volunteered
subcommittees make recommendations so
if you can't come to an agreement about
your recommendation then they you just
tell us that and then the rest of the
committee will decide what to do
okay so hb609 relative to energy
house bill I mean Senate Bill 280 no
House Bill 281 which was heavily amended
by the Senate implemented some of the
reforms that were contained in House
Bill 609
but there very likely are other reforms
that we could make to the site
evaluation committee so I recommend that
we form a subcommittee
to see what else can be done
with hb609 if we strip out the six or
eight pages of stuff that's already been
implemented in law it'll be a much
smaller Bill much more compact so I
recommend a subcommittee to study that
bill and I will volunteer to be on that
subcommittee
any other volunteers representative
McGee Mr chairman I just wanted to make
a comment we had uh 10 members of our
committee at the New Hampshire energy
Summit
and that was on the 18th and there was a
panel that discussed site evaluation
committee changes that they would make
so I think we have some good
recommendations to bring to that study
committee and I'll volunteer to be on it
as well and I have the names of a couple
of other people who also already said
they'd be interested if you need more
names
representative Kaplan you're
anybody else
okay I will be the chair of that
subcommittee we have one two three four
five members so we will proceed with
that one
that brings us to House Bill 616
relative to administration of the New
Hampshire's renewable portfolio standard
this was a bill
by representative McLean to
add nuclear to the
renewable portfolio standard and we
didn't think the bill at the time that
we passed judgment on it I and retained
it I don't think we believe that the
bill was ready there were too many
unanswered questions about how this
whole
addition would
work and affect the RPS
so the question now is should we form a
subcommittee to study this issue
or should we study this issue when the
LSR that I've submitted to change the
renewable portfolio standard to a clean
energy portfolio standard
comes before us
I vote for the ladder
I vote for the latter okay
representative Summers that's your clean
energy LSR include nuclear yes it does
Okay so we will uh
I tell this bill then is it likely to be
the representative Harrington on your
bill
um does it this I believe this bill and
I haven't looked at it while the one
we're looking at right now also
basically
um just takes the renewable energy and
lumps them into one gets rid of the
class system so it says somebody can go
out and this is how much renewable
energy you must buy you figure out
whether it's going to be solar or wind
or qualifying Hydra or whatever does the
well as representative Bernardi said
about his laddering bill the details are
not nailed down at this point okay
um I can certainly
add that to the bill
or we could consider
moving forward with this bill taking out
the nuclear part and just considering
the uh
anybody have any thoughts on that on
I would think it would be cleaner to
just do it all at once with the bill
coming up next year than try to work
with two separate bills and okay it just
seems too common census all right so
we'll probably
all right next is HB 622 repealing the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board as you'll recall
House Bill 281 is amended by the Senate
did that so this bill
as it exists or as it is written
is no longer useful but I suggest that
we amend the bill by replacing the
language in the bill with language that
encourages the grid modernization
Advisory Group that was created by
Senate Bill 166 last year to add Energy
we have language that has been offered
to us that does that
and I suggest that that might be the
best way to go at this bill your
thoughts
additional thoughts
representative McWilliams
are you proposing a subcommittee to
discuss the language on the amendment or
you just want to float an amendment that
we can early before well before the 31st
I'm proposing that we float an amendment
that sounds good I'll submit that
Amendment this week and once OLS
prepares it I'll send out the amendment
to the to the committee
okay
and last but not least is HB 631
relative to electric utility smart meter
Gateway devices
so this bill
is a bill to uh
allow customers optionally to purchase
Smart Meters from their utility I guess
the language of the bill states that it
has to be a smart meter that the utility
so the question becomes do we want to
allow this
would it
make a difference would anybody take
advantage of it
would anybody spend the extra money to
buy a smart meter even though they might
wait until the utilities decide
how they want to use smart meters
representative Thomas
thank you Mr chair um Mr chair we've
gone through several of these type bills
over the last several years and they
haven't really gotten too much traction
a lot of
like what you said in terms of waiting
for the utilities to come out with
something there's been questions about
the definition of what a smart meter
really is there's been concerns about
health effects there's been concerns
about privacy effects
um yeah I think I would be in favor of
just italing this bill
other thoughts representative lewicki
thank you Mr chairman
um I agree with representative Thomas I
don't think that
this is really a matter for legislation
I think this is something that can be
between the utilities and their
customers and if the utilities become
invasive or you know amazing privacy or
so forth then it may be a area for
litigation rather than legislation
additional thoughts representative McGee
I had a bit of a hand in the original
bill and I can tell you that the and I
wasn't here when it was prevented
because I was out
um but the original intent of the bill
was to make uh it non-mandatory but
optional for customers to be able to
upgrade the technology that they have in
their home to a smart meter if they
choose to and the idea is that the
utilities would have to decide what
grade of meter and what type of meter
would be appropriate for people to
purchase so that they would be able to
contribute to the infrastructure that we
will be moving to in the future because
I think that information is already
known and all of the utilities in New
Hampshire are not in the same place in
terms of the upgrade of their
infrastructure so that it has the
technical capabilities to do certain
things that we'd like to see them do in
the future and my thought was
if a migration to
um to smart meter technology ends up
being mandatory or being adopted by the
utilities in the future that are not
there yet then that would be a very
expensive cost shift to the rate payers
so the idea of allowing people to in a
voluntary way people who are early
adopters and who just like technology or
want to be able to have access to that
information if they were able to invest
in that technology which is a relatively
small cost for a homeowner
in advance of a major migration then we
would be upgrading the technology by
people's opting in basically and so the
idea is not to wait for a mandate that
we're moving everything
which will be expensive and a cost shift
but to at least make the technology
which is now available out there uh
something that's promoted through the
utilities so that people can opt in if
further comments representative
Harrington yeah I'm just wondering uh if
the representative from eversource would
eversource did testify in opposition to
this bill originally
representative closure thank you chair
there's there is also groups out there
that do not like these smart meters we
hear of them they're worried about their
EMF output so I would like to not
advance hitzel itl
other thoughts representative Thomas
Doug Thomas thank you Mr chair
um
well I I I do agree with the intent of
the voluntary nature of this bill which
I think is uh more of my liking in that
respect I still think that this bill
would be premature because there's
really nothing out there yet and the
utilities certainly aren't proposing one
yet and then we run a risk of someone
buying a few people buying something now
we're maybe in two or three years it's
surpassed by different technology so I I
think it's a little premature in in that
respect although the voluntary nature of
representative partial thank you sure
I think we already have had an
opportunity to weigh in on uh on the
local magnetic output of these smart
meters where the build was came up
earlier we all decided that that was
insignificant so to bring it up now I
find a little bit disingenuous
I would also add that um I do not like
the bill as written I think that we have
early uh innovators in the state such as
unitel who've gone to Smart metering
committed to it fully and they have
actually created the software to have
time of day uh transactional
time of use time time of use uh billing
I think that has to be the wave of how
we're going to modernize the Grid in
order to flatten our demand line and
flatten the Curve and to basically
reduce the cost of our electric car to
our consumers I think the itl this is a
bad move I think we ought to actually
instead perhaps have a study committee
on it it might not be the best Bill but
I think it's a bill that certainly
deserves our attention and can be
further comment representative Wendy
Thomas
thank you Mr chair
um just to talk about a statement you
said we are a couple people have said
about waiting for the utilities to make
a decision there's no incentive for them
to make an immediate decision and I
think that part of our job is to light
fires under them to force decisions for
so how does this bill do that I it's
it's optional it's it's kind of
independent of this bill it's just the
the statements that were were made
around here
um I mean I would like to see
Smart Meters become available for those
who want them the early adopters I would
but without some kind of a utility
program to take advantage of the smart
meter what does it buy you I right but
but for us to wait for the utilities to
tell us when they're ready to do it I
think that that's kind of backwards I
think we should be demanding of the
utilities that that they they in
put in this this kind of Technology
we've been fighting a smart meter
without a utility program to take
advantage of it be like buying a
computer with no software
representative lewicki uh thank you Mr
chairman there are in my experience
numerous ways that people can monitor
their power usage real time other than
using the meter itself you can have us
some kind of current census on your
wires whatever and I'm certain that such
things exist and if somebody wants to do
it then they can do that without any
privacy risks and without having to wait
that's true I'm at my utility New
Hampshire Electric Co-op offered me the
opportunity to buy such a device I think
it was 259 dollars
and it would monitor all the appliances
in my house and tell me
what I was using representative McGee
yeah I just wanted to clarify because
the idea that only the utilities would
be able to help you to
use a Smart Meters output is inaccurate
there are applications you can have on
your phone that help you interact with
your meter and those can also be used by
groups like the community power you know
we're starting to create a competitive
market in New Hampshire having a smart
meter is not
only a utility for a customer maybe
utilities of Runway but only helpful to
a customer if they have a utility to
interpret it for them I think
the data is something that is not
necessarily just going to be a construct
of the utilities going forward so I
think that's a misnomer to feel that you
can't use it if your utility isn't ready
to help you read it
representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair you left us hanging
um did you buy the smart meter
say again you left us hanging
did you buy the smart meter that was
proposed I did not okay thank you it was
a good deal but I didn't buy it
I don't really care how much electricity
my refrigerator uses so
all right I don't sense a a strong uh
desire here to form a subcommittee on
this one so we'll just have to let this
one go as it will whenever we get to
Executive session
and with that we have gone through the
entire list according to my notes we
have formed three stub committees one
for 159
which consists of
Bernardi McWilliams Wendy Thomas Summers
and McGee
then we have formed another subcommittee
for HB 558
which is representative Doug Thomas
representative Wendy Thomas Tom closure
and representative McGee
and the last subcommittee is hb609
Representatives Vos McGee Kaplan
Harrington and Corman
is that correct representative Doug
Thomas thank you Mr I Mr chair I propose
that uh whoever we get as our new
Committee Member be put onto my
subcommittee
okay
if he is so willing I'm willing to
what's that representative Wendy Thomas
or her
or her yes correct
okay uh I think we have representative
naughter
do you know when you're going to have
these subcommittees
as I explained at the beginning of the
session the subcommittee chairs will
decide when to call a subcommittee
meeting
being well aware of the fact that it has
to be published in the calendar at least
four days prior to the meeting so for
example
if you wanted to have a meeting
subcommittee meeting next Monday as long
as you got it into this week's calendar
but it's going to be up to the
subcommittee chairs to schedule these
meetings
working in conjunction with the members
that makes sense seem fair
okay
all right any further business to come
representative closure
thank you chair I'd like to make an
announcement comment about the
study committee on assessing generation
thank you
uh four of us from uh st e
were are on the
it's a commission to study the power
generation as assessing
um
the chair pat abbromi
looked at it and what he'd done the
years before
and would like to extend this committee
so we would have enough time to complete
it right now it ends in I believe
November
um
November 1st yes of this year
24.
is it 25. yeah I'm I'm so sorry
of 23. so we're going to need more time
um he was asking if stne
could
renew this committee for another year
that was to 25 November 25.
um also in discussion
uh renewing It Is by either adding as
Amendment or using one of the itl bills
to extend the study Commission
in our discussion
um representative munz
uh recognize that there's four of us on
St e on a commission that's really
um assessing the value of these
Generations there's not much
um
power being talked about is just how do
we assess the infrastructure so
it was brought to us for I think we have
a
agreement that
two would be enough from s t e you know
four isn't Overkill there's a senate
appointee and maybe ways and means I
will let
Mr bramy decide but
I think we had a consension debt four
from STNA is too much for the next
um
if we make a bill for extending it so
that would be a change
representative Gorman thank you Mr
chairman yeah if I may just add on to
what uh representative said the
committee the commission as it currently
is constituted has five members of the
house uh representative roachford from
Ways and Means and then for from this
committee Representatives Munns Summers
poche and myself
and we what we're looking at is how to
assess these properties for taxation
and you know this is just not in the
Wheelhouse of of people from this
committee it's in the Wheelhouse of
people from Ways and Means so uh what
what we're thinking is that if we do put
through a bill to extend the life of
this subcommittee to sometime in 2024
excuse me not something commission to
sometime in 2024 that the bill also
recommend at least a certain number from
Ways and Means so that uh the people who
actually know how to deal with taxes are
properly represented
okay so let me ask the committee would
you guys be open to the idea of creating
an amendment to extend this assessment
commission and modify its membership
and using House Bill 458 which we were
going to itl
as the vehicle to do that
so we could replace all of the text of
458 including its title
and extend the assessment commission's
life until
November of 2024
is that a long enough time
it should be in theory
in theory okay
what do you think representative Doug
Thomas yes but thank you Mr yeah I yes I
agree and one major reason why I agree
is because the four Representatives that
are on this commission right now weren't
here a few years ago when a similar tax
assessment bill came through our
committee for electric utilities and
although we did a value attempt during
that one year we quickly advised when it
came through again it needed to be go
going somewhere else because as the
gentleman stated we are not tax
assessors and just because it has the
word generator or utility or energy
doesn't necessarily mean it it's it's in
the proper committee so I I really
support an amendment to uh to make those
changes because uh I don't want to go
through this again because we're not tax
assessors
representative Harrington yeah this this
issue has been going on for I don't know
the 20 years I've been involved in the
state house so if there's a chance they
need a little bit more time to finish it
up let's finish it up and get it done so
I strongly support giving the extra year
further comments representative Munns
thank you Mr chair I I just wanted to to
follow up and say that you know the
reason for trying to do it with a bill
that we are talking about right now is
so that hopefully what we can do is get
it expedited through the house through
the Senate so that the amount of period
that will lapse between when the
commission expires on November 1st and
it gets to start up again will be very
short
that's why an amendment
would work correct
seeing none we will proceed that way
could I ask representative Corman and
representative closure to work on said
Amendment
and send it to the committee as soon as
you can get it prepared
by OLS
and you can certainly work with
representative abrami to a former
representative of brahmer II
make sure you get it right
okay any further business to come before
seeing none I think we're done adjourned
for today and we'll see you soon take
care